mi a különbség ak között hogy valakinek
vannak nárcisztikus jellenvonásai ahogy
nekem is vannak neked is vannak és
mindenkinek pontosan és valakiről azt
mondjuk hogy ő már nárcisztikus ugye a
grandiózus nárcisztikusok
azok
udvarnokokat szerveznek maguk köré tehát
udvartartással
[Zene]
rendelkeznek sziasztok nemrég fejeztem
be a beszélgetést bence edittel
pasztorál pszichológussal a nárcizmusról
beszélgettünk nagyon kemény és nehéz
téma volt arról beszélgettünk hogy
milyen is egy nárcisztikus jellenvonás
honnan lehet felismerni hogyan lehet
kezelni és hogyha benne vagy egy ilyen
toxikus kapcsolatba akkor hogyan tudsz
ebből kimozdulni felépülni hogyan tudod
az önbecsülésedet növelni tényleg sötét
téma és én is érzem magamon hogy lehúz
bizonyos szempontból viszont annál
fontosabb hogy megnézzétek ezt az
epizódot mert hihetetlenül praktikus és
szemfelnyitó epizód lesz számotokra és
kérlek ne felejtsetek el feliratkozni
ugye és ezzel segítitek a munkánkat
következen az
epizód köszöntöm minden kedves
hallgatónkat a mai napi vendégem bence
edit és köszönöm szépen hogy még egyszer
elvállaltad ezt a beszélgetést isten
hozott a stúdiónkba megint én is
köszönöm szabolcs hogy újból itt lehetek
hiszem hogy lesz ennek egy mély célja és
egy mély értelme amit itt tudunk
bontogatni köszönöm az biztos mert a
célja ennek az hogy beszéljünk a egyik
legnehezebb témáról számomra legalábbis
a nárcizmusról amikor kiment a a közös
epizódunk ami amúgy elég népszerű
epizóddá vált sokan meghallgatták és sok
visszajelzést is kaptunk az egyik
visszajelzés az az volt hogy ők nagyon
szívesen hallottak volna a nárcizmusról
egy pszichológustól mert úgy pedzegettük
forma a témát de és és ismernek engem a
a azok akik ismernek engem tudják hogy
számomra ez egy fontos téma úgyhogy
úgyhogy emiatt is kértem hogy gyere
vissza és beszélgessünk egy kicsit még
tovább specifikusan erről a kérdésről
ami valamiért ennyiember t foglalkoztat
nem tudom hogy neked mi a tapasztalatod
de én négy évvel ezelőtt bár tudtam hogy
ez a szó létezik valahol hogy a hogy a
nárcizmus az egy a a a az egy görög
mitológiában egy egy történet amikor
beleszeret a saját tükörképébe nárcissus
az hiszem és és úgy úgy érteni véltem
vagy úgy emlékezni véltem hogy hogy ez
ez ez valami fogalom a pszichológiába de
hogy ez mit jelent pontosan és hogy
miért releváns az én életemben
ez ez ez két évvel ezelőtt kezdett
nagyon-nagyon
mély vágás lenni és rájöttem arra hogy
hú emögött rengeteg szenvedés van
rengeteg valós szenvedés akár ami ami
engem vesz körbe de úgy úgy mindenhol
jelen van ez általában és egyre többször
hallok olyan kifejezéseket hogy
gázlángozás háromszögelés
szürke sziklatechnika és egyre többször
merül fel ez a a nárcisztikus viselkedés
vagy a a a a nárcisztikus jellem mint
kifejezés úgyhog úgyhogy neked is ez a
tapasztalatod amúgy hogy ez egy nagyon
népszerű téma lett manapság pontosan
nagyon bekerült a köztudatba és ugye
hogyha kiemelem külön azt a szót hogy
toxikusság vagy toxikus
2018-ban ez a szó az évnek a szavalett
tehát annak megvan a mély háttere hogy
miért is lehetett az ugye akkor kezdtünk
el intenzívebben foglalkozni azzal hogy
mit jelent hogy toxikus kapcsolatok mi
áll mögötte és rengeteg kutatás
visszaigazolja azt hogy a toxikus
kapcsolatok mögött nárcisztikus
aspektussággal vagy nárcisztikus
személyiségzavarral való működés
áll hát talán a legjobb pont hogy
elkezdjünk beszélgetni erről a témáról
az hogyha egy definíciót hozunk hogy te
hogyan definiálnád hogy mi az hogy
nárcizmus mi az milyen egy nárcisztikus
jellem ugye rögtön már szinte mondhatni
hogy bárki akit megkérdezünk az önimádat
szót odakapcsolja hozzá de hogy mégis az
önimádat mögött ott van egy öngyű őlet é
az az önimádat valamiből eredet
eredezthető
á nem tudom kimondani oké és
igazából kétféle
elválasztási formája létezik tehát
kétféle definíció ugye van a nyílt és
van a rejtett nárcisztikusság tehát amit
én emelnék tehát a nyílt nárcisztikusság
a grandiózus nárcisztikusság az a
fölényből táplálkozó működést
mutatja tükrözi tehát egy hamis én van
mögötte egy grandiózus énkép van mögötte
tehát a kapcsolatim belül nincsen meg a
tisztelet nincsen meg az alap
szabályszerűségeknek vagy a szabályoknak
a betartása és a rejtett nárcisztikusság
az ugye egy ilyen passzív agresszióval
egy büntetőmorral ilyen jellegű
büntetőmodorral
való létet tükrözne hogy egy picit
hogyha bontogattjuk ezt akkor még úgy be
tudunk mélyebben a rétegeibe is érkezni
ennyit mondanék önimádat fölényből való
táplálkozás
felsőbbrendűségnek a tükrözése másokból
való mások dinamikájához való
nem valós hozzáállás tehát egy
hamisított hozzáállás satöbbi de hogy
kibontjuk azt hogy milyen módon hát
börénik e akkor akkor menjünk bele
konkrétan hogy mit jelent a nyílt vagy a
grandiózus nárcizmus és a a rejtett
nárcizmus mind a kettőről egy kicsit
hogyha jellenvonásokat tudnál mondani h
hogyan lehet felismerni ezeket
tehát először visszavezetném oda hogy mi
az amire visszavezeti ugye az én szakmám
hogy egy picit így képbe kerüljünk ha ez
így jó tehát ugye a korai gyerekkori
sérülésekkel kapcsolja össze vannak
kutatások amik a genetikai részt is
behozzák viszont érdekes már freudnak
volt egy olyan mondata hogy a jóléti
társadalom is a bölcsője tud lenni annak
hogy valaki nárcisztikussá válik tehát
ha ezeket így külön szedegetem vagy
külön szálazom tehát a rideg
atmoszférában felnőtt korai gyerekkori
tapasztalatokból táplálkozik egyik felől
másik felől a túlfűtött túlóvott
túlkényeztetett gyerek
kis el tudja ezt a szintet tehát el tud
kerülni ide úgymond és ugye a jóléti
társadalomnak az atmoszférája a bölcsője
meg tudja ezt így teremteni
szociokulturális hatások is ráhással
vannak ilyen módon erre
szétszállazván tehát a nyílt
nárcisztikust az különbözteti meg a
rejtett nárcisztikustól akár majd a
dinamikáról is tudunk beszélni hogyha
úgy gondolod vagy úgy látjuk így menet
közben hogy egymásra hogyan hat a kettő
vagy együtt hogyan képesek ők
összedolgozni vagy összefonódni mert
ugye van egy olyan kulcszó is egy picit
egy zárójelt ide megejtek hogy
nárcisztikus kodependencia és hogy ők
nagyon jól tudnak például ilyen módon
összedolgozni jó egy picit akkor
visszatér k arra hogy a nyélt
nárcisztikus abból ismerhető fő hogy nem
megkérdőjelezhető tehát bárki ha
szembesíti őt azzal hogy ne amit
elkövettél vagy tettél most ebben a
helyzetben vagy megnyilvánultál velem
szemben valamilyen módon ő rögtön
kritikának veszi a kritikát nem bírja
elviselni általában az a reakciója hogy
hatalmas impulzussal tehát impulzus
kontroll van jelen náluk tehát
visszadobja arra aki
behhozta a meglátását és elkezdi
befeketíteni az egyént tehát visszamutat
rá hogy ezért te vagy a hibás te vagy az
aki ezt kihoztad és hogy ő magáért tehát
azért a cselekvésért amit ő tesz nem
vállal felelősséget említettem azt hogy
van egy ilyen
felsőbbrendűségi tudata tehát egy ilyen
istenképszerűség jelenik meg nála hogy
én magam a hatalmas én magam a nagy
satöbbi satöbbi tehát ez így külön
válaszhat hogy a rejtett nárcisztikustól
hogy ismételjem és a rejtett
nárcisztikus viszont
ő nagyon sok jót próbál cselekedni
másokért de a háttérben az van hogy
valahol a dicsőséget csendesebben
rejtettebb úton akarja bevenni mindazért
amit ő ad vagy
amó h mag pontan pontosan pontosan igen
és nála viszont ez a működés tehát egy
ilyen passzív agresszióba bedurcázik
generál ilyen fur a helyzeteket ami
szintén így a befeketítési technikákhoz
közel tudja vinni az egyént azaz a
nárcisztikus áldozatokat adott ponton mi
szerinted miért beszélünk ennyit most a
nárcizmusról én úgy gondolom és elég
sokat gondolkodtam meg hogy én is évek
óta foglalkozom ezzel a témával ugye
bibliai aspektusok alapján is a
tudományos vonalat én úgy próbálgatom
nézegetni a kettőt egyb vett vele ahogy
a múltkor is ezt megfogalmaztam én úgy
gondolom azért mert hogy annyira sok
eszköz adatott a kezünkben hogy egyre
inkább a pszichoedukatív látásunk tágul
és szélesedik tehát bekerült miatt a
köztudatban mertogy foglalkozva van vele
tehát információéhes társadalom vagyunk
részben ezért foglalkozunk vele de
másrészt egy picit hogy tovább vigyem a
gondolatot azon kívül hogy információ
éhes társadalom vagyunk én már úgy látom
hogy nem elég hogy csak az legyünk hanem
mögötte szükséges van szükség van arra
vagy szükségün van arra hogy
transzformáció
formálódás átformálódások jöjjenek ki
tehát nem pusztán információra hanem
transzformációra lenne szükségünk és úgy
gondolom hogy minden ilyen eszköz ami
informatív jellegű hozzá tud járulni
ahhoz hogy transzformatív legyen egy idő
után ugye attól függ az hogy mennyit
időzünk el amellett mennyire engedjük
hogy átjárjon bennünket egyik kedvenc
kulcskifejezésem vagy kulcszavom úgymond
hogy a rácsodálkozás
mennyire vagyunk hajlandóak
rácsodálkozni elidőzni engedni hogy
átitasson az a kulcszó vagy az a
gondolat amit éppen tanulmányoztam vagy
közel engedtem magamhoz amint engedem
hogy befele menjen elkezd formálni tehát
az
információéhesség az információk utáni
kutatás hozta közel részben azt hogy
ennyit foglalkozunk mindezzel meg egy
picit egy idézet ahogy készültem ide úgy
eszembe jutott vagy nem is egy idézet
egy volt szó de egy idézet is amire a
későbbiekben majd kitérek gyökösi endre
fogalmazott úgy hogy
a bibliával összefüggésbe hozva azzal az
igével hogy lesznek napok az utolsó idők
így fogalmaz de hogy a napok azok amiken
gonosz időket generálnak amikor az
emberek lesznek önzők önmagukat kedvelők
önmagukat szeretők versengők satöbbi
satöbbi ott egy jó pár
felsorakoztatás meg van jelenítve és úgy
fogalmaz gyökös ilen re hogy ezek az
idők az egoitiszt generálják tehát az
itis az gyulladást jelent így külön egy
orvosi szakkifejezés és ugye begyullad
az ego begyullad az én és úgy gondolom
hogy most éljük azokat az időket amikor
a múltkor ahogy beszéltünk vagy amikor
beszéltünk az identitásról és a jóléti
társadalomról hogy ez mind-mind
hozzájárul ahhoz hogy az eg
begyulladtabbá váljon vagy begyulladtá
váljon és ha van akinek van is még
affinitás
ö mindenre akkor még inkább meg tudja
meg tud ágyazni a korszellem ezzel
kapcsolatosan vagy erre nézve
igen hát ha ha én én
most ha tehát vizsgáld meg az én
gondolatomat ezzel kapcsolatban igen a
én úgy látom hogy ez a közösségi média
igen ez hozott egy olyan elkezdte
jutalmazni a nárcisztikus viselkedést
igen amikor kiposztolunk magunkról valam
igen vissés valójában most ha egy
mondatba próbálnám összefoglalni talán a
legjobb definíció a nárcizmusra az hogy
valaki úgy akar társadalmi státust
elérni hogy nem dolgoz meg érte olcsó
győzelmeket akar aratni és egy hamis
képet kialakít magáról amit pozitívan
díjaz a világ amiatt mert könnyű könnyű
gyümölcsöket egyszerű alacsonyan függő
gyümölcsöket akar leszedni és ez lassan
lassan kezdi torzítani a az önmagáról
alakított képet és ahhoz hogy fenntartsa
ezt az önmagáról alakított képet ezt
folyamatosan
kell manipulatív eszközökkel erőltetve
fenntartsa és ez egyre jobban torzítja a
dolgokat és egy pár ilyen jellenvonást
észrevettem amúgy amúgy azt kiemelném
hogy én azt látom hogy fontos hogy
kiemeljük hogy mindenkinek vannak
nárcisztikus jellenvonásai és mindjárt
egy mindjárt fel fogom tenni a
legfontosabb kérdést hogy mi a különbség
a között hogy valaki nárcisztikus vagy
pedig nárcisztikus jellen vonásai vannak
de előtte azt mondanám még hogy számomra
egy fontos jel ami alapján felismerek
egy személyt aki nárcisztikus az a az
empátiának a hiánya igen ami ami egy
nagyon fájdalmas dolog mert olyan amikor
valakivel beszélsz aki tegyük fel még
okos is ráadásul és tudja míemmelni az
empátiát de valójában az empátia hiánya
az ami teljesen jelen van olyan mint
amikor belenézel egy tükörbe de nem
látod az arcképedet vissza nem néz rá át
nem nem reflektálódik semmi hanem
mindent mindent elnyer amikor beszélsz
egy egy ilyen személlyel fogalmad sincs
hogy ki vagy egy idő után nem reflektál
vissza rád semmit vagy pedig amit
visszareflektál az egy torz valami
pontosan a másik az a az a mély
arrogancia ami jellemzi egy ilyen
nárcisztikus jellemet ha most a rejtett
nárcisztikusról beszélek akkor az a
típusú ember akit biztos mindenki ismer
pár ilát hogy ha én megkaptam volna azt
a lehetőséget amit amúgy nem kaptam meg
tehát másfelel érte
akkor én ilyen és ilyen eredményeket
elértem volna vagy a grandiózus
nárcisztikus amikor egyértelműen kiáll
és elmondja hogy én mekkora király
vagyok és és ehhez hozzátartozik mivel ő
nem akkora király valójában ezért
folyamatosan gázlángozik manipulál a
gázlángozásról is akarok beszélni külön
de ez egy ez egy nagyon-nagyon toxikus
fajta manipuláció a gázlángozás és
mindegyik mögött ott van az
áldozatmentalitás valójában hogy amikor
valaki nem hajlandó felelősséget
vállalnios akkor abban a pillanatban van
ha mindenki más felelős akkor azt
jelenti hogy én vagyok az áldozat és
hogyha magamat áldozatnak hirdetem ki
akkor implicit benne van az hogy lehet
hogy akkor mások a hibás a ezért úgyhogy
most ezt az öt dolgot amit így
megemlítettem ezt látom talán közösnek
minden egyes ilyen nárc akár rejtett
vagy
grandiózus jelnek amit elég hamar fel
lehet ismerni ha valaki figyel ha valaki
egy idő után tudja hogy hogy hogy mire
figyeljen mi erről a véleményed így
összefoglalóként így alap pontosan
nagyon örülök hogy kiegészítetted ez úgy
mind bennem volt gondoltam hogy így
menet közben be beemelődik így a
csemegézés úgymond ha lehet ennek
nevezni persze de egy kicsit fájdalmas
ugye ez a rész a fájdalmas csemegézésre
gondoltam igen teljesen egyetértek ez
így van és
igen igen nagy igent mondok rá ez pont
így működik tehát az empátia hiánya
nagyon jelen van az arogáns viselkedés a
viszonyulás nagyon jelen van a rejtett
nárcisztikussal kapcsolatosan eszembe
jutott még az hogy ő áldozatnak mutatja
be magát tehát úgy lehetőt a leginkább
felismerni hogy vele mindenkor mindenki
elbánik pedig ő jót tesz folyamatosan
visszaélnek vele pedig ő bizalmasan
közeledik a grandiózus azt viszont nem
így állítja be hogy ő az áldozat hanem
hogy ő a nagy és amit említettél ugye
hogy a médián keresztül a
visszatükröződések
igen ott van tehát egy image tükröződik
vissza de az az image az valahol nem egy
kőbevéset nem egy maradandó hanem valami
áll lepel alatt működő vagy álarcot
hordozó és hordozott image igen nagyon
alá tud ásni akár ugye a gyerekeink
jövőjének akár az ifjaknak a jövőjének
mert hogyha az influenzerekről beszélünk
mi az amivel befolyásolják őket hogyan
veszik őket körbe milyen hálót kerítenek
köréjük é úy ahogy mondtad ugye hogy nem
a a fönnebb lévő gyümölcsökért próbálnak
kinyúlni hanem a lenét a könnyet a
könnyűt amiért nem szükséges annyira
megdolgozni vagy kitartani vagy magáb az
influen
pontosan p köreszi egy ilyenítos hogy
könnyen gyorsan híres és gazdag tudz
lenni pontosan pontosan pontosan csak
ugye nagyon ingovány a talaj amire
építkezve van általában a háttérben
úgyhogy
igen akkor akkor menjünk a másik nagyon
fontos kérdéshez mi a különbség ak
között hogy valakinek vannak
nárcisztikus jellenvonásai ahogy nekem
is vannak neked is vannak és mindenkinek
pontosan és valakiről azt mondjuk hogy ő
már nárcisztikus ö nagyon jó a kérdés
köszönöm tehát egy spektrumon helyezhető
el van az alacsonyan működő spektrumú
nárcisztikus nekik önbecsülés problémáik
vannak van az egészséges spektrumon lévő
akinél ugye ott van az hogy az
önmegvalósítás az önérték öröme az
önbecsülés öröme az az egészséges
nárcisztikus és nagyon jó hogy az van
és bizakodóak vagyunk vagy ugy a
környezetünkben akárha szemléljük hogy
vannak olyanok akik így mernek őszintén
jólzanul akár kiülve emberekkelé te is
ezt a bátorságot ahogy így behoztad
tudod hogy valami jót építesz meg hogy
tovább adsz valamit tehát van az
egészséges spektrum és ugye van az
amikor már a skálának a felső részén
helyezkednek el az már a
személyiségzavarra utaló jel vagy tünet
de azt ugye klinikusok pszichiáterek
által
megállapított diagnózisokból lehet
felismerni de hogy ezek a tünetek vagy
ezek a jellegzetességek azért ott vannak
amikről beszéltünk és ahogy mondtad ha
valaki ezzem szemléli vagy figyeli egy
idő után elég könnyen észreveszi hogy
érintettsége lehet bizonyos személynek a
k pont it nem gondoltam erre de akkor
megismétlem amit megértettem belőleigen
tehát a spektrum tetején a nárcisztikus
személyiségi zavar van ami már klinikai
esett és erről tudsz valamilyen
statisztikát körülbelül a társadalomnak
hány százaléka
hát tudtam most azon gondolkodom de nem
olyan nagy százaléka van diagnosztizálva
csak 1 skról tudok én azért mert
általában nem mennek el ugye hogy
segítséget kérjenek és emiatt tehát nem
is tud annyira kiszűrődni vagy annyira
nyilvánvalóvá válni hogy az
össztársadalom hány százaléka érintett
én 1%-ról tudok és a spektrum alján
akkor ott vannak az alacsony
önbecsülésűek igen miért különbözteted
meg a spektrum alját a közepétől mi a mi
az ami különbség a kettő között
szerinted egy picit érdekes ugye mert a
múltkor az identitásk kérdés most már
harmadjára is hozom be de nem tud nem
élni bennem meg annyira belém ég ott az
a beszélgetés hogy ha nincs ott az az
identitásudat akkor elmozdítható vagyok
az egészségestől tehát ugye akár
kimozdulhatok felfele mozdulhatok vagy
lefele mozdulhatok ha nincsen meg az a
kösztes identitástudat tehát az az alap
az a bázis és enélkül valóság az ami az
önbecsülést tudja alátámasztani vagy
megágyazni ugye ez is visszajelzések
hogy voltakada mennyire volt
elmarasztaló mennyire volt ö nem
reflektív a felnövekedése egy gyereknek
de hogy mégis na tehát így akár a
későbbiekben is az ki tud alakulni
nagyon intenzíven hogy az önbecsülésnek
a zavara akár a ttinnédzserkori reakciók
vagy a válaszok amik érik őket tehát
eléggé tág a a szféra
én talán ennyit hoznék idebe most tehá
hogy ha megpróbálom meg megismételni
megint amit megértettem hogy talán nincs
egy éles határ mert egy spektrumról van
szó persze persze de azért mégis csak
valamiért két külön kategória rakjuk ezt
a igen azért rakjuk két külön
kategóriába és azért nincs éles hatás
nagyon jó a kérdés mert időnként ki az
aki nem küzd valamennyit egy-egy
önbecsülészavarral vagy nincsen esetleg
egy olyan fázis ahogy bizonyos
területeken megkérdőjelezi önmagát tehát
azért nincs egy ilyen éles határ tehát
időnként van egy-egy arányi valamennyi
csuszkálás de ugye van olyan akibe úgy
már eleve bele van égve hogy ha ránézünk
és úgy látszik hogy ő nem tudja
értékelni vagy nem tudja becsülni magát
vagy nem tudja úgy fogadni el magát
ahogy alkotva van p ez hogy ezt a szót
használtad hogy bele van égve ez olyan
szempontból érdekes hogy dr ramani amúgy
ő az egyik szaktekintély most így a
világon nem tudom hogy konkrétan
hallottál vagy olvastál-e tőle valamit
én én én az ő podcastjeit hallgattam
nagyon sokat igen ő a kalifornia
egyetemnek az egyik professzora kutató
professzor és amúgy egy nagyon híres
podcaster is és ő elég határozottan
mondta azt hogy egy nárcisztikus személy
egy nárcisztikus jellem nem fog változni
és ez ez ez egy borzasztó amikor én
erről hallottam először ez egy
pokoljárással volt egyen értékű nekem
mert a keresztény nevelésem nem engedte
ezt a a a gondolatot magamhoz közel mert
a keresztény nevelés azt mondja hogy
hányszor kell megbocsátani valakinek
70zer
hétszer ki tehát hogy hogy ki az aki
bűntelen hát én sem az dobja rá az első
követ aki bűntelen
úgyhogy valahogy úgy voltam vele hogy
hogy én én nem itélhetem meg az embert
ki tudja hogy fog-e változni vagy nem
fog változni ramani valójában azt mondta
hogy statisztikailag ő nem látott
egyszer se olyan releváns változást ami
tényleg tényleg számítana tehát hogy
lehet hogy statisztikailag van
valamennyi változás de ez kábé úgy
képzel mondta fel is hívta a figyelmet
úgy képzeljétek- el hogy egy toxikus
nárcisztikus aki abuzálja otthon a
családot nem 8olc órát kiabál otthon
hanem csak t órát kiabál ez nem akkora
nagy változás nyilván óraszámban 30%-kal
kevesebbet kiabál de mégis a a családnak
az élete pokol ugyanattól kezdve úgyhogy
úgyhogy felteném ezt a nagyon provokatív
kérdést számodra is hogy szerinted egy
nárcisztikus jellenvonású személy fog-e
tudni
változni érdekes amit mondtál hogy a
keresztény alapelvek amiket otthonról
hozol és ugye abba bele van valahogy
forgatva az a reménység hogy hát
mindenki változásra kész hogyha odateszi
a szívét az istennel való járásra vagy
akár ugye a megtérés kulcsot is ide
hogyha ha beemelem é hogy mi hogyan
látjuk akár keresztényekként hogy van-e
rá lehetőség én nem tartom kizártnak de
tényleg az eddigi statisztikákra hogyha
visszatekintünk akkor elég kevés de ugye
egy picit a statisztikai adatokat azzal
is összefüggésbe hozom hogy %-a van
diagnosztizálva a társadalomnak tehát
na egy annyit tudok amikor tanultuk mi a
pszichopatológiát akkor az egyik tanárom
kiemelte volt hogy rengeteg türelem kell
hozzuk és hogy ezen a területen van a
legkevesebb változásra való hajlandóság
meg a legkevesebb változás és tudom hogy
kiemelt egy-két
nevet akkor annak idején több évvel
ezelőtt akik foglalkoznak nárcisztikus
személyiségzavarral élőkkel de hogy
nagyon nagy türelem szükséges hozzájuk
mert de it megintem választuk a
nárcisztikus személyiségzavart és magát
a nárcisztikus jellenvonástak a
spektrumáját pontosan pontosan pontosan
tehát a ramani azt mondja hogy az
emberek szer min 15%-a ez a fajta
jellenvonás igen igen ezt kérdem hogy te
hallottál-e valami ilyesmit mert ezt
ramani mondja viszont kíváncsi vagyok
hogy a te kutatásaid vagy a a
tanulmányaid alapján milyen igen igen
tehát én itt most a személyiségzavarról
beszéltem az alsó
tehát a 15% amiről te tettél most
említést én ott nagyobb változásokat
vagy nagyobb változásokról hallok mint a
felső spektrumon lévőknél a zavarral
élőknél tehát akár bár hogyha én az én
munkámra nézek rá vagy fókuszálok rá az
önbecsülés zavarral élőknél előbb-utóbb
valahol csak beindul valami az őszinte
szívűségük meg az őszinte keresésük meg
ugye egy valódi én valahol csak elő tud
törni megfogalmazódik közelebbé válik
hogy ő kicsoda vagy akár egy gyökérverés
tud jobban történni mint a zavarnál
élőknél é nagyon jó hogy elkülönítődik
nem szeretném egy bemosni és köszi hogy
ezt így most korrekcionáltad
igen tehát mindenképp a tanulmányaim
alapján ez volt
így közölve velünk vagy ezt tanultuk mi
is hogy nagyon kevés
elég járnak-e hozzád olyan ügyfelek akik
akik azért jönnek hogy azt mondják rólam
hogy nárcisztikus vagyok egyáltalán nem
én úgy szoktam fogalmazni hogy
áldozatokkal dolgozom együtt
nárcisztikusoknak az áldozataival vagy
nárcisztikus
jellemzőt hordozóknak az áldozataival
mert ugye nem mondhatjuk ki hogy
nárcisztikus személyiségzavarosok
áldozataiv van hogyha nincsen
diagnosztizálva én ezt kés zárnám mert
hogy nem vagyok klinikus és nem
szeretnék megtéveszteni ilyen módon
senkit meg hogy egyáltalán nem az én
asztalom de hogy az aspektusokat az
intenzívebb módon képviselő
aspektusokkal élőknél láttam olyat hogy
az áldozatok tehát az áldozatokkal való
foglalkozás hogy helyesbítsek tehát igen
olyanokkal van
találkozásom is érdekes hogy ugyanazokat
a történeteket hallgatom végig hogyha
jönnek maros megyéből vagy kovászna vagy
hargita megyéből különböző városokból
falvakból nem ismerik egymást és
ugyanazokat is ugyanazokat mondják tehát
nem tudom nagyon-nagyon sokszor már íy
már így visszaigazolódott hogy hú hát ez
a történet olyan ismerős csak éppen most
valaki
másnak igen mond cak a amikor amikor én
küzdöttem ezzel a problémával az egyik
megoldási mód mert a környezetem nem
nagyon értette mi történik és és nekem
egy pokoljárás volt megérteni hogy most
mi történik körülötte mert annyira
kemény gánzlángozásban volt részem
annyira annyira megingatta az alap
alapjaimat hogy valójában a amit
gondolok a világról helyes-e és mindjárt
belemegyünk hogy miért ennyire toxikus
beiratkoztam kerestem egy csoportot a
facebookon és volt van ha ha kedves
nézők rákeresnek akkor egyből lehet
kapni öt csoportot például van olyan
hogy nárcisztikusok túlélők csoportja
18000 taggal és
beiratkoztam és volt az egyik hölgynek
amúgy túl túlnyomó többségében az
áldozatok hölgyek igen és és túlnyomó
többségben a nárcisztikusok azok
általában férfiak de azt hiszem hogy
olyan 8020 meg a megoszlás
az egyik hölgy én nagyon frappáns
mondatot írt azt mondta hogy nektek
nincs a az érzésetek minthogyha mind
ugyanazzal a pasival járnánk vagy mind
ugyanarról a személyről lenne szó
minthogyha egy nagy hrm lennénk ahol
ahol ugyanaz a személy és ez ez persze
vicces kacagtak az emberek rajta de
nagyon elgond gondolkoztam ezen a
mondaton mert mert tényleg annyira a
jellenvonásokat meg lehet nevezni
mintaszerűen megismétlődikosan prediktív
lehet lehet előre jósolni szinte hogy
hogyan fog viselkedni valaki hogy hogy
szinte olyan mint egy matematikai képlet
és hogyha ha neked is gyakorlatilag pont
ezt erősítetted meg hogy hogy
visszaköszönnek újra és újra ugyanazok a
dinamikák ugyanazok a minták és én
emlékszem hogy 17 mintát írtam össze
amit felismertem amit konkrétan meg is
tu ttam nevezni
és ez valahol elgondolkoztató hogy ez ez
ez miért van így és hogy hogy miért van
18000 tagja ennek a csoportnak és hogy
ha tényleg ramaninak igaza van márpedig
ki vagyok én hogy azt mondjam hogy a egy
szaktekintély azt mondja hogy 15%-a az
embereknek az a kategória ami már
toxikus ak és hogy ennyi szenvedésly is
van mögötteehát valójában lehet hogy
pont ezért is beszélgetünk most erről
mert ennyire ér mindenki ismer egy pár
ilyen személyt maga körül akik akik
arrogánsak lehet hogy rejtetten lehet
hogy hogy önmagukat áldozatként
bemutatva én sosem kaptam meg azt a
lehetőséget amit megkaphattam volna t
stílusban de valahol elszívják az
energiát folyamatosan mivel áldozatnak
mutatják be magukat mennek az emberek
hogy felemeljék hogy segítsenek és nem
változnak soha nem változnak mármint
hogy ezt nyilván nem mondhatjuk ki de
hogy az az érzésünk hogy már
belefektettünk most már erről két éve
beszélgettünk már öt éve beszélgettünk
már mindent megadtunk minden lehetőséget
és még mindig ugyanazzal a problémával
küzködünk és még mindig van valami amire
mutat ilyenkor például egy nárcisztikus
személy mindig azt mondja hogy igen de a
a a ha ha azt megkaptam volna de az a
hibá esleg igazából nem olyan géneket
örököltem meg nem an nincs annyi pénzem
meg igazából a a munkahelyem sem úgy
alakult a covid után pedig ezekkel a
nehézségekkel küzdöttem és mindig van
egy válasza arra hogy most éppen miért
nincs jól vagy miért miért nem jönnek
össze neki a dolgok
úgyhogy úgyhogy igen szóval nagyon
megerősített amit mondtál hogy hogy a te
tapasztal is ugyanaz mint hogyha
ugyanarról a személyről lenne szó
ennyire felismerhető ez spirituális
szempontból egy picit olyan is olyan is
azérés kíváncsi vagyok mi a véleményed
mint hogyha ha ahogy amikor az emberek
fejlődnek akkor végtelenül színessé
végtelenül
összehasonlíthatatlanul izgalmassá
válnak nem teljesen más személyiséggé
viszont mint amikor amikor elkezdenek
visszafele fejlődni olyan minthogyha
csontvázakká válnának minthogyha
lefogynának és az egyik csontváz pont
úgy néz mint a másik csontváz alig lehet
megkülönböztetni egymástól a
csontvázakat mert mind a mindegyik
hasonló felépítése van és olyan mint
hogyha spirituális szempontból éheztetve
lenének ezek az emberek és hasonlítanak
ugyanúgy éheznek ezek az emberek viszont
ha ha az ellenkező utat választanák
akkor teljesen más briliánsan szikrázóan
színes spektrumon mozognának az emberek
mindenféle szépség tehát mint mint a
virágok egy egy egy virágos mezőn
mi a véleményed erről hogy hogy erről a
gondolatról hogy hogy a csontvázak
hasonlítanak egymáshoz úgy ahogy a
nárcisztikus jellenvonások is nagyon
hasonlítanak egymáshoz pontosan
megszólít amit mondasz olyan szempontból
is ugye hogy van a nárcisztikusságnak a
grandiózus
művelőnek úgymond vagy a
grandioózitással élőnek összezsugorítja
az áldozatát tehát összezsugorodik az
aki a jelenlétében van és valahol hogyha
behozom ide most az igei
reflexiókat pál olyan szépen kibontja a
timóteust figyelmeztetvén hogy lesznek
az emberek
önmagukat kedvelők te pedig timóeus
tartózkodj az ilyenektől tehát aki túlon
túl önmaga képébe beleszeret ugye ez a
nárciszis történet nárcisz története
tehát mi történik amikor ilyet látsz
magad körül tartózkodj ő tőle tehát igen
van az összezsugorodás van az hogy
csontvázakká válnak tehát valahogy úgy
fogalmaznék hogy úgy lekerül róluk az
élő és az eleven hús tehát
lerágja ez a működés ő róluk és ahogy
beszéltél még az is megfogalmazódott
bennem hogy szerintem ember nincs aki
valamilyen módon vagy egy főnököt aki
bír hasonló jellenvonással vagy egy
rukont vagy egy házastársat vagy valakit
aki a környezetében baráti körében ott
van jelen van ne próbálta volna meg
kiszeretni a
nárcisztikusságából tehát mindenkor
kerülünk bele vagy mindannyian inkább
így fogalmaznék kerülünk bele olyan
helyzetbe hogy észrevétlenül valahogy
belesodródunk lehet hogy sokszor nem
tudatosan hogy szeressük ki őt valahogy
onnan és ugye egy keresztény alapelv is
az hogy hát akkor segítsünk rajta
viszont itt én egy picit külön
választanám nem tudom belemehetünk-e
most a témáb jó
kérdész és egy picit itt külön
választanám azt hogy a jó hozan segítő
meg a az olyan módon segítő aki áldozati
szerepben marad benne tehát van az
áldozati segítő az én meglátásom szerint
nem baj ha a saját életem áldozata árán
de van a józan segítő ugye a józan
segítő példájához talán a leg inkább a
amikor
az irgalmas szamaritánius a samaritánius
az útszélén fekvőnek megkegyelmez
úgymond előtte elment egy pár ember vagy
mellette elment egy pár ember de
összeverve sebekből vérezve vagy
sebektől vérezve otthagyják és annyira
tetszik ez a történet és nagyon jól
tükrözi a segítői étos például vagy a
segítői mintázatot a józan segítői
mintázatot hogy egy bizonyos időn
keresztül vállalja be a segítést tehát
elviszi a pontból b-be fölteszi a
szamarára és beviszi a fogadóshoz és
rábízza és azt mondja hogy viseld a
gondját és én majd reggel visszajövök
tehát ez a józon segítői atit hogy
valameddig lehet hogy rám bizatott iss
valahogy olyan módon bizatott rám hogy
szükséges azt a felelősséget vállalnom
akár önmagamért vagy akár a józan
meglátásomért vagy akár a családom meg a
mentális épségem érdekében vagy épségünk
érdekében mert itt akárha 18000 tagból
tevődik össze az a facebook oldal amire
bejelentkeztél tehát ez óriás é azóta
még több meg vagyok győződve tehát ugye
merhetek vagy merek többes számban is
beszélni tehát a józan segítői attitűd
az hogy próbálom feltérképezni hogy
meddig az én részem és ott van ugye a
másik rész amikor áldozattá válunk benne
olyankor valahogy úgy fogalmaznám meg é
az eddigi tapasztalataim is azt mutatják
hogy az áldozatok külső segítség nélkül
nem igazán tudnak kijönni ebből a
dinamikából tehát az a dinamika ami
éltetődik a háttérbe az áldozatokat
szükséges segítenünk adott ponton hogy
ők tudjanak kijönni persze aki így
érintett benne vagy aki összetalálkozik
áldozatokkal vagy akinél vagy milyen
módon ugye látja hogy megnyílnak emberek
tehát valahogy egy józan kinyúlás
mindenképp tehát ezt a kulcszót hoznám
ide be hogy a józan segítői attitűd
meddig az én részem hogyan van hol van
az én részem ugye itt viszont
szétparcelláznám hogy én mint segítő
vagy én mint családtag vagy bárki mint
családtag tehát nem egyszerű tehát nem
úgy működik hogy akkor nekem az apukám
anyukám akárkim rokonom testvérem is
akkor hagyjuk az egészet és jövünk ki
belőle hanem hogy lehet ott
megfogalmazni vagy megragadni azt hogy
nekem eddig van az a felület ameddig én
el tudom vinni ott még hatékonyan tudok
jelen lenni az életében de egy idő után
már mind a kettőnknek akár de főként
ugye az áldozatoknak bomlasztó az az
attitűd amibe belevonódnak újból meg
újból és igen egy picit pál szavaira
visszavinném a gondolatmenetet hogy
timóteus te pedig tartózkodj ezektől
tehát egy jó a tartózkodásra inti pál az
ő tanítványát úgymond timóteus
tartózkodj ezektől
igen hát a a a erről szerintem most kell
egy kicsit még beszéljünk hogy mitől
annyire toxikus a nárcizmus
mert az aki nem találkozott vele mármint
biztos mindenki találkozott vele de
mivel felületes és hogyha felületes
kapcsolatokon keresztül ismerjünk meg
valakit nem jövünk rá hogy mennyire
toxikus valami de elmondok egy pár
példát hogy valaki értse hogy valójában
mennyire súlyos ez a dolog és és akkor
utána bele tudunk menni hogy mit tud
csinálni addig nem nem nagyon akarunk
megoldani egy problémát ameddig nem nem
tudjuk így például egy olyan családi
dinamikában ahol az egyik fél
nárcisztikus például tegyük fel mivel
gyakrabban a a férfi ezért vegyünk egy
ilyen családi modellt ahol van egy
grandiózus nárcisztikus férfi vagy pedig
egy egy egy rejtett nárcisztikus férfi a
nárcisztikus
egy mű mesterséges képet tart tart fenn
a családjáról kifele úgy tűnik
minthogyha az a család teljesen rendben
lenne viszont tegyük fel amiután
elmennek egy partiba és ő a a társaság
közepe a mókamester kedves empatikus
odafigyelő és amikor beülnek az autóba a
parti után és becsukódik az ajtó és már
senki nem hallja elkezd
üvölteni és és a a a feleség pedig
amikor egy jó pár éven keresztül
ugyanezt tapas alja egy idő után egy
ilyen kognitív diszonanciába kerül hogy
hogy ez ez mi én nem értem és a ami még
rosszabb az az hogy hogy ezt ő elkezd
önmagába kételkedni a nárcisztikus fél
megerősíti ezt azt mondja hát igen
kételkedsz magadban mer én is ezt mondom
hogy veled van a baj és akkor utána
elmennek megint egy ilyen társaságba
megint előadja azt a sót amit kívülr ez
elő szokott adni és akkor jönnek a
barátok akik akik körbevették a családot
és odamennek gratulálni a feleségnek
hogy milyen jó férjed van milyen vicces
biztos nagyon szerencsés lehetsz és
akkor ha ilyenkor fel mer szólalni mint
feleség hogy hát de állj meg otthon
teljesen másképp viselkedik akkor azt
mondják hogy hálátlan vagy hát nézz meg
mennyi mindent csinál érted tehát ez egy
ilyen lefele vezető spirál ahol lassan a
másik fél megőrül valahol a másik fél
felőrlődik ebbe a toxikus kapcsolatban
és és olyan minthogyha ez egy nagy-nagy
szerepjáték lenne ahol vannak statiszták
nem csak a kétfél van és és ez nagyon
gyakori és ez nagyon gyakori úgyhogy
ezért is akartam ezt például ezt a képet
felhozni mert ez munkahelyen is
megismétlődhet és egy egy jó pár más
kapcsolatban megismétlődhet ez az
iszonyatosan toxikus helyzet és ennél
még tovább megyek majd később példákkal
de
hogy ilyen példákkal találkozol legyen
eg egy könnyű labda amit feladok hozzád
jönnek-e olyan áldozatok akik pont ilyen
kapcsolatban vannak
igen találkoztam ö egyik jellemzőként
még be tudom emelni azt is ahogy
beszéltél így eszembe jutott hogy ugye a
grandiózus nárcisztikusok
azok
udvarnokokat szerveznek maguk köré tehát
udvartartással rendelkeznek úgymond
tehát ugye jönnek a barátok és mondják
hogy juj milyen jó fej a te férjed meg
nem tudom mi emlékszem hogy megérintett
egy alkalommal egy történet hogy valaki
megosztásából
az jött át hogy és mondják hogy milyen
jó fej és én közbe sírok meg könnyezek
mikor látnak akkor befele de odahaza
kifele mertogy otthon teljesen más
valamit mutat és hogy ugye ezek ilen
nagyon mély rejtett fájdalmakként ott
vannak az egyénekben ott van a
működésükben igen tehát az udvartartás
az udvarnokok tehát el
alájátszanak bedolgoznak ő néki de amit
érzékelek ha közeliek azok a személyek
mert ugye egy baráti kapcsolatból
könnyebb kilépni és itt megint külön
emelem hogy egy rokonsági szálban
vagyunk-e benne vagy van-e benne valaki
vagy pusztán egy baráti kapcsolatban
tehát amikor a rokonok lesznek
udvarnokok és elvégeznek olyan munkákat
merthogy megtéveszti őket a
nárcisztikusnak a működésse akkor
valahol úgy fogalmaznék hogy még inkább
és még inkább azt az áldozatot aki ott
van és ővéle lakik a közvetlenül
érintett áldozat még inkább a lejtőn
lefele tudja ez a dinamika és egy idő
után emlékszem egy valaki úgy
fogalmazott két gondolat is eszemőt hogy
hogy fogalmazott egyik egy olyan mondat
volt az ajkairól hogy egyszerűen edit
odakerültem hogy még magamat is
megkérdőjelezzem-e a
döntéshozatalomban tehát régebb nekem
nem jelentett gondot az hogy akkor barna
kenyeret vegyek vagy fehéret de most még
azt is megkérdőjelezzem hogy jó döntése
hogyha a barna kenyeret veszem tehát
ilyen alap bármit itt most mondtam egy
példát de bármit megkérdőjelez önmagával
szemben vagy önmagával kapcsolatosan és
emlékszem hogy még egy alkalommal egy
ilyen nagyon intenzív segélykiáltás több
ilen van csak most ahogy így eszembe jut
hozom be ide megosztásként volt egy
ilyen kérdés hogy edit mondd meg hogy
annak a dinamikának amit ő felépített
velem szemben hogy
megkérdőjelezi azt amit én láttam vagy
amit én tudok ugye ha a szakmai részt
nézem akkor a valóság észlelés t
kérdőjelezi meg az egyénnek aki ott van
mellette a társának akár és volt olyan
kérés hogy mondd meg hogy hogy tudjam az
ő technikáit valahogy átjátszani hogy
túl tudjam élni és emlékszem hogy az
volt a válaszom hogy verhetetlenek ők
ezekben a technikákban tehát akinek a
személyiségébe ez nincsen beépülve vagy
beépítődve úgymond bizonyos nehéz
helyzetekből kifolyólag ugye hogy az
létrejött amint az elején már említettük
nem tudjuk ezeket a technikákat
alkalmazni megkövetni tehát ezek olyan
szálak meg olyan háló
beépítések meg olyan behálózott
effektusok úgymond hogy akinek ez nincs
beépülve nem tudja ezt működtetni tehát
ez a verhetetlenség kulcs szó talán amit
ide beteszek hogy nem tudjuk nyomon
követni nincs ahogy nyomon kövessük
tehát nincsen meg az a kellő
felvértezett fegyverzet úgymond hogy
tudjuk átlátni hogy akkor na a következő
lépés tehát így igen egy idő után van
egy rá látás de hogy a technikákkal
úgy kapcsolódni ahogy ő kapcsolódik
fordítottan tehát ez most nem is
működőképes ugye tehát hiába is
próbálnok alkalmazni nem tudjuk de
hogyha mégis minimális részét
alkalmaznók mivel nem a mienk és nem a
mienkép vált hanem utánozván őket
alkalmaznók
jönne létre valami olyan ami még inkább
torzítaná a kettőjük közötti vagy a
kettő közötti kapcsolatot és most
behoznám még azt a kolcot hogy van az
átmágneseződ
az átfertőződés tehát egy idő után
beemelhetem-e ide ezt mi a véleményed
vagy hogy gondolod tehát egy idő után
kösz szépen legalább tudjuk miről
beszélünk egy idő után tehát átveszi azt
amit tehát beleívul abba vagy
beleidomodik abba úgymond az áldozat
hogy tényleg ha ő meg van kérdőjelezve a
saját valóságával nemet tényleg vele van
a baj tehát átmágneseződik áttevődik rá
befertőzi ez a működésőt és ön magát
kérdőjelez megíarálni valakinek
azésétes teljesen valahol olyan
megfogalmazást is olvastam hogy a
húsdarálóból szükséges az embereket
kimenteni ez volt az egyik legdurvább
megfogalmazása hideg is ráza hogy most
ezt így megfogalmazom vagy így
visszaidézem a másik meg ami így nagyon
erősen dobogott bennem ezzel a
húsdarálós történettel kapcsolatosan ezt
mondom egy cikkben olvastam még azt hogy
karaktergyilkos működéz tehát igazából a
jellemét forgatja ki a karakterét
mélyenben az identitást forgatja ki
tehát a sok megkérdőjelezés meg a
valóságérzékelés megkérdőjelezése
kapcsán és egy picit talán ugye a
zsugorodást mondtad a csontvázolást
mondtad és másik felől a növekedést hogy
én azért nagyon bizakodó vagyok hogy az
áldozatoknak a növekedését ahogy láttam
vagy ahogy képesek lettek egy idő után
hogy felvérteződtek arra hogy valahogy
csak lehet változásokat meghozni persze
nem egyszerű tehát hosszú időn keresztül
tartó folyamat de csak megragadnám ezt a
részt is majd a későbbiekben akár én
arra gondoltam h most e van vagy igen
most hét-nyolc dolog amit leírtam olyan
fogalom amit jó hogyha tudnak a
hallgatók igen kicsit bevezetném
elbeszélgetnénk róla és miután
felvérteztük magunkat ezzel a tudással
hogy valójában szerintem mindegyiknél az
emberek elkezdenek rádönni hó ez ez
ismerős és amikor már kellőképpen
úgymond körberajzoltuk hogy mitől is
toxikus egy ilyen helyzet akkor hagyjunk
időt arra hogy beszéljünk potenciális
menekülő útvonalakról és és
megoldásokról hogy ne csak a sötét
oldalát de azért tartom fontosnak
beszéljünk a sötét oldalról mert addig
nem veszi az ember komolyan ezt a
ameddig nem nem jön rá hogy hogy
valójában ez komoly pontosan és velem is
úgy volt hogy az a a személy aki aki
számomra ezt az egész krízist okozta az
életemben a jéghegy csúcsa volt amit
láttam és úgy voltam vele hogy hát ez ez
kicsi dolog majd kinövi még fiatal és
ahogy mélyebbre és mélyebbre és
mélyebbre mentem úgy egyre sötétebbé
vált minden és és és rettenetessé és és
én bizonyos szempontból stupid módon a
legmélyebbig mentem ameddig mehettem
tehát konfrontatív módon szembementem és
és emiatt egy számomra is egy egy ilyen
leforrázás volt hogy találkoztam a
mélységeivel a nárcizmusnak de ezáltal
is tudok most beszélni egy kicsit
szabadabban ró róla úgyhogy bevezetnék
egy pár fogalmat például a legyen a
szerelembombázás az első mint kifejezés
én azt értettem meg a
szerelembombázással kapcsolatban hogy a
nárcisztikus személyek gyakran gyakran
karizmatikusak nagyon elbűvölőek
viccesek odafigyelőek főleg a grandiózus
fajta egy erőteljes személyiség amelyik
amelyik nagyon gyorsan nagyon jól eladja
magát és az az érzésed egy beszélgetés
után hogy vow ez aztán egy egy
szuperember ez ez ez nem csak hogy
kompetens hanem érzékeny alázatos is még
meg hogy hogy hogy kiemeli hogy hol volt
áldozat de hogy hogyan küzdött meg ezzel
és a végén az vagy hogy vow egy
szupersztár hát ez ez jackpot és és a a
nagyon határozottak a nárcisztikusok és
a főleg a fiatal hölgyek összetévesztik
a
kompetenciát a
a a a nárcisztikus jellenvonással mert
egy nárcisztikus személy is is
határozott és egy kompetens ember is
határozott úgyhogy nehéz a csak a
határozottság alapján eldönteni hogy
most ez valódi kompetencia vagy pedig
álkompetencia amivel találkoznak és
akkor itt jön be a szerelemb bombázás ez
egy ez egy hihetetlen gyors érzelmekkel
teli időszak amikor a nárcisztikus fél
kitapogatja hog a másik fél mit szeretne
hallani és pont azt mondja a másik fél
pedig ha ha tényleg naivv akkor megeszi
ezt
és és akkor akkor tegyü fel nagyon
gyorsan például jellemző az hogy egy
párkapcsolat nagyon gyors tempóban
elkezd fejlődni pár hónap múlva már
házasságba
házasságnál kötnek ki és akkor persze
amikor a szerelem bombázása elérte a
célját úgymond akkor kifárad a
nárcisztikus mert nem bírja ezt
fenntartani ezt az áképet és utána jön
egy leértékelési fázis és akkor a
leértékelési fázis mélypontjában amikor
azt látja hogy veszíti el a másik
személyt akkor megint jön egy
szerelembombázás és akkor megint
összeszedi és azokat a szavakat mondja
amit tud tudja hog hallani akar a másik
fél és gyakorlatilag ez a
szerelembombázás ez a ez a felle felle
ez a a
a a a a ez ez ez a
folyamatos különbség érzelmi különbség
annyira kifárasztja azt a másik felet
hogy egy idő után már a se tudja mi az
igaz mi a helyes nem tud és és és na ez
az egyik fajta toxikus számomra
sötét-sötét eszköz amit folyamatosan
tapasztalok hogy amikor találkozok egy
nárcisztikus személlyel már meg tudom
mondani ez most szerelembombázás most
engem el akar bűvölni mindenféle vicces
dologgal mindenféle helyzettel és persze
ez férfi férfi között is működik tehát
amikor a vagány
képét próbálja eladni a kompetens képét
meg meg most már úgy vagyok vele hogy
azért egy lépést hátrább lépünk gyorsan
ne döntsünk pillanatok alatt egy-két nap
alatt most ne döntsük el hogy az a
személy
személyről pontosan mi is a helyzet
úgyhogy itt át is adom a szót mi a
véleményed erről a szerelembombázásról
találkoztál-e ezzel a fajta
viselkedéssel és milyen milyen egy-egy
történetet is elmondhatsz esetleg
hogyhazedbe igen nagyon szívesen rögtön
történetek is jutottak vagy történet
jutott most itt eszembe többek közt
valaki úgy fogalmazott hogy mire azon
kapta magát már beleszeretett tehát
annyira gyorsan működött olyan gyors
tempóval hogy valahogy már rég a karjai
közt volt mire
fölébredt és amikor már megtalálta vagy
megkapta az áldozatot ugye úgyis
fogalmaz úgy van megfogalmazva ez a
kifejezés hogy
nárcisztikus üzemanyag tehát kapott ő
egy üzemanyagot kapott egy töltést
amiből ő tud működni amiből ő tud
táplálkozni amikor megkapta akkor hagyja
elengedi hosszabb kötélre és eszembe
jutott az a dal hogy a sebeveletse
nélküled hogy régebb nem fogalmazták így
meg hogy nárcisztikusság vagy
nárcisztikus aspektus de lehet hogy a
sebeletse nélküled valamilyen taszítalak
visszavonzalak tehát mivel a grandiózus
nárcisztikus nem bírja elviselni a ugye
róla hoztál be egy gondolatot vagy a
kérdést hozzákapcsoltad nem bírja
elviselni a veszteséget tehát
visszaporszívózza az áldozatát tehát
igen nagyon intenzíven ott van a
szerelembombázás és újból meg újból
kinyúl érte és vissza porszívózza
megvannak azok a az alap effektusok ami
alapján ugye kiismert ahogy te is
fogalmaztad és újból vissza tud nyúlni
érte tehát az egy biztosítás neki egy
belsőbebiztosítottság kívülről
táplálkozván persze de hogy a régi
módszereket újból meg újból éli újból
meg újból visszatér hozzám nemrég
olvastam egy cikket hogy érdekes módon a
táskereső oldalakon is a legtöbb aki
jelen van grandiózis nárcisztikussággal
bíró igen tehát a hűtlenség egy abszolút
jellemző vonása hogy hogy amik a
kapcsolatot valahogy össze tudta
hozni szerelembombázással meg és amikor
már nagyon-nagyon optimálisnaken
akkoréked aner na mostantól kezdve jön a
menország akkor kezd keresni máshol
leértékeli a másik felett már megunja
már pontosan tehát össze tudja gyorsan
hozni a kapcsolatot ahogy mondtad de nem
tudja megtartani mert ahhoz hogy
megtartás és elköteleződés legyen ugye
ahhoz szükség van a valódi énre é így
egy hamis én van mögötte a másik addig
az egyén azaz az áldozat akit
visszaporszívózott ugye újból meg újból
ahogy én láttam így a tapasztalataim
alapján reménykedik abban hogy na most
na most ahogy te is fogalmaztad tehát
igazából élményekből táplálkozik tehát
nem a valóságból hanem az élmények
kezdik el éltetni és ezért od akkor a
jelentőséget hát ha ez már ötször
megtörtént hát akkor hátha most még
tartósabb lesz még tartósabb lesz és
sajnos többször azt láttam meg az évek
folyamán hogy így mentek le 10 évek 20
évek 25 évek egy-egy áldozatszerep
betöltéssel egy-egy nárcisztikus
aspektussal bíró mellett
így jöhetünk így jöhet be most a
következő fogalom is amit át akarok
beszélni ez a
kenyérmorzsázás mint kifejezés ez pont
erre a seveled sené küledre utal hogy
mindig adunk neki egy kenyérmorzsát ami
éppen nem hal meg a másik fél tehát
amikor már azt látja hogy túl nehéz a
helyzet akkor akkor akkor ad valamit
hogy ott ott maradjon volt egy nagyon
érdekes kép ami van egy párátalanítónk
otthon amelyik folyamatosan fújja a
levegőt és a kisfiam játékból egy lufit
odavitt és egy olyan érdekes pozíciót
kapott el ahol az a lufi nem tudott
elszabadulni hogyha távolodott akkor
visszaszívta és hogyha ha ha közeledett
akkor elnyomta és ez ez ez ez annyira
vizuálisan megragadt ez a kép hogy
valójában pont ezt csinálja egy
nárcisztikus hogy nem enged túl közel
magához viszont nem akar elengedni sem
és a másik fél nem tudja hogy most mi
történik mert ő alig várja hogy valami
intim mély kapcsolat legyen hogy végre
meg tudjunk nyugodni végre ki tudjunk
ülni a tenger partra úgy hogy nem
vitatkozunk és megiszunk egy egy koktélt
közösen és és a mennyországot megéljük
ezt is mondja nárcisztikus hogy hogy
engedj bízzál benne minden jó lesz alig
várom hogy ez megtörténjen és amikor
végre ott lehet akkor valami durva
dologgal egy egy kés beleszúr és
eltávolítja magától azt a személyt és és
ez ez ez ez a pokoli oldala ez a pokoli
oldala a nárcizmusnak szóval ez a fajta
kenyérmorzsázás amikor éppen csak annyit
adunk a más másik személynek hogy ne
halljon meg ez kikészíti teljesen az
idegeit a a a másik félnek pontosan két
gondolat jut eszembe egyik a az egyik
magyar népmeséből a három nácsál
kisasszony ugye vizet vizet mert ha nem
meghalok és hogyha időben nem adja a
vizet a királyfi akkor tényleg meghal az
a király kisasszony a harmadikot
valahogy azzal a vízzel csak sikerült
megmenteni tehát a kenyérm morzsázás
éppen csak egy pici megmentése az
aktuális helyzetnek az akkornak csak
annyit kapsz hogy most egy kicsit menjen
tovább a mi kapcsolatunk de ugye hogyha
nézzük a hátsó tartalmát a mélységét
ennek az egésznek tehát igazából a társő
kenyérre vágyna és ő élteti a reményt
magában hogy na nem baj akkor a sok
morzsából valahol hátha össze tudok
tenni egy ép kenyeret de nem fog lenni
abból kenyér és ugye annak a felismerése
hogy a morzsák nem elégítenek meg egy
idő után már nem elégítenek meg az azért
egy óriási út igen na menjünk még lenebb
akkor a mozsákkon lenebb igen a fö a a a
toxikus skálán a következő az amit amit
még megtapasztaltam ez a gázlángozás ez
egy olyan szó amiről nem hallottam
előtte viszont manapság mint mint ige
használjuk mármint hogy hogy egyre
többször lehet hallani angolul a
gaslighting magyarul a gázlángozás
kifejezést
ez a kifejezés ez arra utal amúgy egy
filmből jön nem tudom tudtad-e igen
tudtad akkor ha akarod elmesélheted te
is hogy igen nyugodtan meséld én egy
picit más egyebet hoznék be majd ezzel
kapcsolatosan egy személyes r egy egy
nagyon érdekes
fogalom ez egy filmből jön be a 30-as
években volt egy olyan film aminek az
volt a címe hogy gázláng és ott a férfi
egy egy ilyen bűnügyi esetről szól egy
házasságról a férfi valamit keres fenn a
felső emeleten és ilyen
gázvilágításos rendszer volt ahol ha
felgyújtotta fent a lámpát akkor alul
egy picit elhalványodott és amikor
lement a a a feleségéhez aki lent tegyük
fel olvasott akkor megkérdezte a
felesége hogy mit kerestél fenn és a
férfi mondta hogy semmit de hát
lehalványodott a lámpa úgyhogy fent
felgyújtottad a lámpát és valamit
kerestél nem nem halványodott el a lámpa
rosszul láttad és a nő pedig küzdött
küzdött egy ő után el kell döntsse most
a a férjének hisz vagy pedig önmának és
a férjét választotta és amikor elégszer
tagadja a
realitását egy nárcisztikus a másik
személynek egy idő után már azt se tudod
hogy mi a jó és mi a rossz között a
különbség nem nem tudod hogy mikor
hibázol nem tudod hogy mikor csinálsz
bármilyen pozitív dolgot ami neki mert
egyszerűen nincs rendszer és és és a
gázlángozás az amikor folyamatosan
manipuláljuk és tagadjuk a realitását a
másik szemé é neek és ez ezerféleképpen
megjelenhet de ez egy őrítő őrítő dolog
mint például egy példa hogy megbeszélett
tegyük fel a mindig nem akarom a
férfiakat mert mindjárt aztán rá akarok
térni a feminin nárcisztikus
jellenvonásokra is de tegyük fel a
férfi azt mondja a feleségének egy
szerelembombázás alatt hogy gyere
elmegyünk elmegyünk színházba ki tudom
hogy szereted a színházat bocsáss meg
nekem próbáljuk meg ezt új helyre hozni
menjünk el a közösen egyet kiengedjük a
gőzt két hét múlva elmegyünk csütörtökön
színházba a nő lassan elkezdi elhinni
és felépíti magában örvend már készül
frizuráját is megcsinál és akkor
csütörtökön délután 5 órakkor odamegy a
férfiz hogy na nem készülsz mert én
mindjárt készen vagyok és akkor
megkérdezi a férfi hova megyünk mi mire
gondolsz hát hova hát emlékszel
színházba megyünk nem ilenrőne szó se
volt
és akkor meg mondja a nő hogy de de
hogyhogy nem volt szó róla hát emlékszem
hogy beszélgettünk én ilyenreő nem
emlékszem jó de de nem tehát hogy ott
voltál emlékszem ott voltál ott álltál a
kanapénak a túloldalán és akkor v
viatkozz nem emlékszem nem nem ilyen nem
történt de hogy hogy tehát ne ne viccelj
na tehát tényleg ott voltál és nem ne
mondod és akkor egy idő után már
elkezdesz kételkedni a saját
gondolataaiba tehát tényleg vajon én
vagyok megőrülve tényleg nem volt egy
ilyen beszélgetés és akkor akkor akkor a
a tegyük fel a a hogy még rosszabb
legyen a helyzet ha van egy bizonyítékod
arra valamilyen oknál fogva hogy hogy
tényleg megtörtént az a beszélgetés
akkor a másik fé azt mondja te kémkedsz
utánam te tényleg azt gondol ilyen
szinten áll a mi kapcsolatunk és akkor
gyakorlatilag átváltott már az egész
teljesen átvitte ez egy másik technika
amúgy de a a gázlángozás maga az amikor
a másik személynek a realitását tagadod
ez hihetetlenül sötét valami mert a
másik oldalon az van hogy ezért
féleképpen megjelenik például a az ez
amit elmeséltem ez egy példa de a másik
az hogy elmondod a másik személynek hogy
te nem is szeretsz valójában zongorázni
vagy te nem is szeretnéd ezt a dolgot
mert valójában ezt szeretnéd és átírod a
másiknak a realitását úgy hogy am ő után
másik azt se tudja hát azt mondták hogy
nem szeretem úgyhogy akkor nem is fogom
csinálni úgyhogy át is dobom akkor neked
így a labdát hogy egy kicsit jelezd
vissza a a gátlángozással kapcsolatban
abszolút tehát úgy fogalmaznék hogy
megfosztja az eredetiségétől az embert
megfosztja önmagától a saját valóságától
tehát egy ilyen lefosztó kifosztó
tényező annyira bekerült a gázlángozás
kulcszó is a köztudatban olyan jót
nevettem ezelőtt egy hónappal francia
nyelvet próbáltam dolingon keresztül
gyakorolni fél évig abbahagytam és fél
év után újr kezdtem s ahogy újr kezdtem
két-három napig nem
tudtam végezni a feladatot a kis
nyelveckémet úgymond és egyszer csak jön
az email ezzel a kérdéssel edit bence
miért gázlángozol engem hát én olyan jót
nevettem hogy most már a dolingo is ezt
kérdezi tudod hogy ez ez most már
annyira bekerült a köztudatba hát én
olyan jót nevettem hogy én addig soha
ezt így nem láttam tudod hogy na hát
miért újra ébreszteni valamit tudod és
akkor érted a valóságot hát visszahozom
a valóságoc két nap múlva akkor nem
foglalkozom már a leckével tudod és ez
így bedobódott nagyon jót nevettem
persze így na nagyon nagy a súly amit
elmondtál annak és tehát itt tényleg a
saját identitás az eredetiség van
megkérdőjelezve és azt látom hogy egy
idő után fejet hajtanak ennek a
működésnek tehát ugye ahogy mondtad ezt
a színházas történetet hogyha ott nincs
meg az a bölcsesség hogy kivonuljon és
ne fokozza és ne magyarázkodjon tehát
belevonul ebbe a dinamikába és olyan
szinten beőli hogy ez a húsdarálóból
kimenteni vagy kihozni őket tehát igen
létezik és újból meg újból használja
tehát ez egy alap működés ami újból meg
újból megjelenik beépített működés
igen még jut eszedbe példa ezzel
kapcsolatban minél több példa is
személetes példa jut annál inkább
ráismernek a hallgatók hogy miről is van
szó valójában gondolkodom hogy a
tapasztalatokból amiket hallottam most
mit hoznék be hát ez a dulingos volt
ilyen érdekes módon erős ez ugye nem
tapasztal vagyis hogy részben
tapasztalat de hogy nem megtörtént ezem
igen ha eszembe jut akkor egyezzük meg
hogy jelzzem jó ha tetszik ez az epizód
akkor kérlek ne felejtsetek el
feliratkozni a csatornánkra osszátok meg
valamint hagyjatok egy kommentet ezzel
nagyban segítitek a munkánkat következő
a a szóaláta amit szeretnék feldobni
pontos folytatva ezt a történetet amikor
a férfi átvált tegyük fel be van szóítva
a sarokba teljesen átvált és akkor
elkezd mindenféle szósalátát mondani
tehát össze-evissza beszélni pontosan h
te tényleg azt gondolod hogy hogy hogy
én hazudok úgy pont úgy mint ahogy ahogy
édesanyád gondolj rólam mert
egyfolytában édesanyádhoz mész és és
engem kibeszélsz és hogy múltkor is
amikor találkoztunk petivel akkor akkor
pont így kibeszéltetek mert mert mert
egyfolytában azt hiszitteek hogy én mind
mindenben csak rossz lehetek nem nem
vagyok mindenben rossz nem ne gondold
azt hogy én egyfolytában csak tévedhetek
és valójában egy lenyom egy olyan
beszédet oda hogy j utána azt se tudod
hogy már miről van szó annyi mindennel
megvádolt annyi mindenbe áldozatnak
hozta ki magát most külön-külön
mindegyikről egy-egy órát kéne beszélni
de bedobott 20 dolgot és és utána pedig
becsapja az ajtót és elviharzik és
és és és akkor áll a másik személy és
azt mondta hogy én csak én csak
színházba akartam menni pontosan na ez a
ez a szó saláta ez ez egy fájdalmas
dolog és hányszor lehet látni
politikusoknál például ezt hogy
összeevissza beszélnek ugye a lényegről
elterjelik a már azt se tudod hogy miről
van szó és annyi mindent feldobnak annyi
mindent a levegőben hyen nagy zavart
keltenek maguk
körül ezt egy másik technikának látom
amit így mintaszerűen fel lehet ismerni
teljesen jelen van én is többször láttam
és nem követhető tehát nem tudja az
egyén hogy melyik részhez nyúljon hozzá
ha egyiket megfogja akkor fölül van írva
az amit éppen ő ragadott meg tehát ugye
a
nyomonkövethetőségnek a hiánya hogy
mondtad hogy bedobják és hogy mit mi az
amit vesszünk belőle vagy mi az amit ki
tud venni az egyén belőle tehát
megfigyeltem többször hogy ott akarják
tartani a fókuszt csak egy részen de nem
lehet csupán egy résszel foglalkozni
mert rögtön tehát nincsen meg a
nyomonkövethetőség és emiatt utakat
nyitanak meg útelágazásokat nyitanak meg
és több pályát akár hogy ne legyen ott
az hogy akkor én most érintett vagyok
benne vagy ott van az a nyom igen igen
tehát ez ez egy nagyon-nagyon fájdalmas
dolog most megem eszembe jutott még egy
g
e egy tipikus dolehát amikor énközlésben
beszélünk az énközlés az az amikor nem a
másikat minősítjük hanem a saját
érzéseinket meséljük el a másik
személynek hogy ne bántsuk meg ezér meg
egy tagadhatatlan dolog tehát hogyha azt
mondja valaki hogy én megszégyenítve
éreztem magam amikor ezt mondtad akkor
akkor egy normális kapcsolatban ilyenkor
a másik személy elgondolkozik hogy vajon
te miért érezhetted magad megszégyenítve
na most egy gázlángozási technika amikor
tagad ad a másiknak az érzéseit te nem
érezheted ezt és akkor tegyük fel
ilyenkor megint jön a szó saláta hogy
persze mert te érzed magad
megszégyenítve nem én amikor nem tudom
és akkor megint jön egy ilyen ilyen de
ugyanaz a gázlángozási mechanizmus
működik ilyenkor amikor valójában a
másik személy el van nyomva abban hogy
nem érezheti azt amit érz érez pontosan
ugye ide hozom be a hideg empátia
fogalmát tehát az empátia hiány nagyon
jellemzi őket és a hideg empátia ugye
pont ezzel kapcsolódik össze hogy hog
nem adok létjogosultságot annak hogy te
érezhess mivel nekem hideg empátiám van
neked nem lehet ez az érzésed és mi
történik visszadobja rá tehát még
súlyosbítja a helyzetet azzal hogy
visszadobja és megkérdőjelezi tehát ez a
megkérdőjelezés a gázlángozást végig de
végig kíséri és ez a visszadobás tehát
ilyen köpönyek forgató
effektus igazából hogy valahogy úgy
forgatom hogy te viseld el a súlyát
megint egyet forgatok tehát hogy nekem
jó y én emelkedjek magasra de hogy te
hordozd el annak a terhét te légy
igazából a talaj a lábam alatt én rajtad
akarok megállni tehát óriási ennek a
fájdalmi faktora és a fájdalmi hatása az
biztos az biztos igen hát a következő
fogalom amit be szeretnék még így
vezetni
ez gondolkozom hogy melyik is legyen ez
legyen például a szelektív érzékenység
ez amiről beszélgettünk ez a hideg
empátia bizonyos szempontból ide
bekapcsolható hogy azt érezhetnénk
ilyenkor hogy egyszerűen csak
érzéketlenek ezek a nárcisztikus
személyek tegyük fel megszégyenítő
beszól egy olyat hogy hogy nézzel ki ha
ha így mennék ki az utcára én én
elsüllyednék és és például amúgy a
férjeknek egy jó tanács hogy ha azt
szeretnék hogy a feleségük szép legyen
ha azt szeretnék hogy mint egy virág
kinyíljon akkor engedjék őket hogy
kísérletezzenek hogy próbáljanak ki egy
új rúst próbáljanak ki egy új ruhát és
hogyha félrenyúlnak nem néz ki a
legjobban akkor bátorítsák őket mert
hogyha megszégyenítik ilyenkor a
feleségüket vagy a barátnőjüket hogy
hogy nézel ki vagy felvesz egy csinos
ruhát és akkor a azt mondja kurvának
öltöztél hát vedd le gyorsan azt a ruhát
meg nem tudom szóval így lehet valakit
elbátortalanítani és hogyha azt akarják
hogy egy egy megöregedett csúnya
feleségük legyen akkor így tudják a
lehetőlegg gyorsabban elérni szóval a
szelektív érzékenység az hogy ilyenkor
azt gondolná valaki egy naivan hogy hát
egyszerűen nem érzékeny nem érzékeny és
mond intellektuálisan felsorol 10 dolgot
hogy miért nem mert az édesapja
alkoholista volt vagy vagy kemény
székely és és emiatt de valójában az van
hogy nem nem erről van szó hogy nem
érzékeny hanem szelektíven érzékeny mert
hogyha másik személyről van szó akkor
hideg kegyetlen tud lenni de ha magáról
van szó mint a cpa így a bért ahogy
megérzi kilométerek távolságából egyből
tudja hogy hogy itt itt itt valami
változáson tehát ilyenkor jön például a
szerelembombázás hogy így leheletnyi
hanghordozásnyi különbségből megérzi azt
hogy itt változtak az erőviszonyok
valamilyen oknál fogva tegyük fel a
feleség
elmegy bence edithez és akkor hazajön és
egyből megérzi hogy valami reménysug
reménysugár megjelent a másik szemében
és akkor egyből azt mondja na jól elő
vagy te most már elmentél pszichológusz
te most már már mindent tudsz ugye na
gyere mondd meg nekem akkor és és és
persze erről kívül kívülről senki nem
tud erről tehát ugye megint megismétlem
ez a ez a kettős élet ez abszolút
érvényes amúgy eszembe jutott egy másik
példa én szemtanúja voltam egy olyan
telefonhívásnak amikor a nárcisztikus
egyértelműen egy toxikus családnak
belülről én is láttam
y egy depresszív mély nyomott hangulat
volt ahol tojáshéjakon járkáltak az
emberek és akkor csengett a telefon
hívta az egyik haverja felvette és egy
nyájas kedves hogy vagy mi van mi
történt veled és empatikus hogy van a
térded emlékszem igen igen keneges meg
nem tudom mivel és amiután letette a
telefont meggyőződött arról hogy lerakta
tehát nem nem az van hogy hogy véletlen
volt v valami meggyőződött róla hogy
lerakta és egyből utána visszaváltott a
depresszív keserű öreg emberré és és én
láttam tehát nem mondhatja most hogyha
azt mondanám hogy e nem igaz amit láttam
akkor gázlángozna valaki láttam hogy ez
történik és és erről senki sem tud tehát
a kívülről ebből a család ából senki sem
látott semmit hanem hanem ez a személy
volt a a társaság középpontja a a vicces
kedves empatikus figyelmes valaki
rejtett bántalmazás általában a
családokon belül ez szokott
megnyilvánulni és egy picit így
kapcsolódván mindenhez amit megosztottál
igen mindenikre itt is egy egy nagy
igenem van ahogy ugye mondtad hogy egy
férjnek szükség lenne a a vagy a hogy a
feleségét építse és hogy visszajelezzen
és engedjen teret hogy kibontakozzon
megkísérletezzen nagyon könnyen bele
tudnak akadni akár a külső kinézeti
állapotokba tehát bármibe is de hogy
hogy nézel ki megint elhisztál milyen
vagy nem vagy elég szép rövid a bokád
nem tudom mi tehát annyi ilyen mondatot
hallottam és újból meg újyból ahogy
mondtad azon az oldalon a a nárcisztikus
bántalmazottok oldalán vagy
nárcisztikusok által bántalmazott
oldalon is vagy megnyilvánul hogy hát
mintha mi egy hár lennünk mintha
mindannyian ugyanannak lennénk a társai
tehát igen ezek a mondatok újból meg
újból szintén elhangzanak tehát nincsen
tér biztosítva az egészséges növekedésre
ahol szabadság van növekedés ott tud
lenni családon belül is ahol szeretet
van ott tud lenni növekedés tehát
szabadság nélkül nem tud lenni sem
szeretet sem növekedés ugye ez a működés
pont a szabadságban való létet
korlátozza le tehát nincsen ott az a
kibontakozás és a már másik hogy ez a
nagyon intenzív kettősség hogy a
gyerekek milyen disszonanciát látnak
hogy hát apa hogy nyilvánult meg
hallottam egyszer egy olyan történetet
hogy kisgyerekek voltak a családban és
sürgölődött forgolódott az anya mertogy
az egyik nagyon az anya által nagyon
kedvesnek tartott családi barát ment
látogatóba és a férj kezdett üvöltözni a
feleséggel hogy megint hívod azokat a
mnkóbarátaidat meg nem tudom én mi és a
gyerekek úgy négy éves öt évesek ott
forgolodtak az édesanja édesapa körül és
hallották mindezt és beérkeznek a
vendégek kedvesen ajándékokkal satöbbi
és megszólal a négy éves hogy anya ők
akkor a te bunkóbarátaid érted tehát
hogy ez a a torz ráásul el tudom
képzelni pont az anya érzi magát rosszul
ilyen min ő m vol ean igen és még ezt
emeltem volna ki hogy a nárcisztikus
jellemzőkkel bíróknál nincsen szégyen
vagyis van nincsen bűntudat
szégyenérzett meg megnyilvánul de
nincsen bűntudat ugye ezért nem tudnak
ők megbánók lenni tehát ezért nincs az
hogy bocsánat és vétettem is hogy ez
őszinteséggel hangzik el tehát a
bocsánat el tud hangzani krokodilkönnyek
meg tudnak jelenni visszasírja magát
gázlángozik satöbbi tehát megvannak az
effektusok é ugye ide akár hogyha
behozom ezt a háromszögelést is tehát mi
történik egy kapcsolat tegyük fel
lezárul rögtön azt
veszi fókuszba hogy hogyan lehet
befeketíteni azt aki vele meg meg
szakította a kapcsolatot utána belemegy
egy másik kapcsolatba elég hamar az a
tendencia hogy belemennek a következő
kapcsolatba ugye ahogy beszéltünk róla
hogy nincsen a kitartás és az
elköteleződés mint alapjelen és mi
történik egy idő után aki elhagyta annak
elkezdi a
kapcsolatát befeketíteni mintha
táplálékot akarna nyújtani neki hogy
nézd meg de te mégis jobb voltál és ugye
beindulott egy ilyen visszaszerző jtett
technika úgymond és utána viszont megint
kezdődik a gázlángozás tehát a
visszaszerző technika utána gázlángozás
tehát van egy ilyen
struktúrája köszi szépen a kérdést nem
tudom még valamivel egészítsük-e
egészítsem-e ezek mozdult én bennem az
merül fel most már azt hiszem hogy a a
nézők és a hallgatók érzik hogy mennyire
kemény ez a téma és ha jó a sejtés amit
már egy listányi ember a fejükben
ilyenkor megjelen
mert mert mert tényleg őrjítő őrjítő ez
az egész és eddig lehet hogy meg se
fogalmazták magukban a ez a hallgatók
hogy hát én én azt hittem hogy ez csak
egy rossz tulajdonság ami ami
mindenkinek vannak rossz tulajdonságai
de hogyha már mintaszerűen fel tudjuk
lehet hogy már több mint rossz
tulajdonság lehet hogy ez ez ellen már
valamilyen
szempontból védekeznünk is kell fel kell
legyünk készülve nem lehetünk már ilyen
naív naív áldozatok ennek a pontosan
áldozatai ezeknek a dinamikáknak például
még az egyik dinamika
az az hogy direkt kérdésekre nem adnak
direkt választ őrítű megkérdezem a másik
személy ezt miért mondtad és a válasz
erre nem egy direkt válasz ami
kielégíteni bár csak mond azt hogy hogy
és akkor még a legrosszabb dolgot is
inkább halljuk a legrosszabb dolgot mint
az hogy hogy hogy nincs válasz és akkor
erre egy nem direkt válasz egy összekent
össz
össze mocskolt mocsar ingoványos valami
a válasz hogy megkérdezzük hogy miért
mondtad ezt és a válasz erre az hogy
hogy gyermekkorom óta egyfolytáb ezt
kérdezik tőlem az emberek hogy miért
mondom ezt és miért mondom ezt és
valójában a kérdés sokkal komplexebb
mert meg kell vizsgáljuk ebből a
szempontból is meg abból a szempontból
is és hogyha és és egy órás válasz után
az az érzéset hogy most mi a válasz erre
még mindig nem ezt miért mondtad és
akkor még jön egy órás valami őrgítő
egyszer őrjítő és és és ilyenkor az
emberek tényleg azt gondolák hogy akkor
lehet velem van a baj pontosan tehát
ugye ez a páncélzat egy védőeszköz és
eszembe jutt most az a mese amikor a
jancsi és a juliska is mentek az úthon
ugye az apa bevitte az erdőbe a gonosz
mostó a kérésére egy picit ide behozom
ezt a részt és mi történik morzsákat
szórnak az útra és gondolják a gyerekek
hogy majd akkor hazatalálunk de ugye a
mozsákat közben fölszedegetik a madarak
is érts jól tehát amikor kérdez k egy
nárcisztikus aspektussal bírótól vagy
jellenvonásokkal bírótól nem lehet
eligazodni tehát azokat a morzsákat
amiket reméljük hogy hátha megtalálunk
és nyomot találunk a szembesítésre hátha
ad egy választ vagy a kérdés kérdésre
lesz egy konkrétum nem találjuk és nem
leljüks ugye ide megint beemelhető a szó
salátázás tehát annyit mond hogy nem
lehet kivenni belőle a lényeget tehát
annyi ferdítés és ez amit még kiemelnék
erről nem beszéltünk hogy rengeteg tényt
átferdétt hiába hogy megtörtént hiába
hogy ott volt együtt voltak az
eseményeken bármi annyira átferdítti
tehát a hazugságokat beépíti és olyan
szinten
valóságosként tünteti föl hogy tényleg
nincs az a nyomkövető most ér z aki ezen
így el tudna igazodni a a vységükre
legyen mondva igen azt látom hogy ők el
is hiszik ezeket ig ők elhiszik teljesen
teljesen tehát én nem azt szeretném
feltüntetni hogy akkor ők a gonoszok és
gyertek gyerünk világgyűlöljük és nem
ilyen gonoszak meg nem tudom é én
valahol mégis csak meg tudom azt ragadni
hogy ők is valahol az isteni tervnek a
részei és hogy nekik is van lehetőség
valahol arra hogy odafordulás vagy
átfordulás legyen ha eddig a
statisztikai adatok azt bizonyítják hogy
kevés is a változás de mégis úgy van egy
bizakodásom hogy az a kevés is talán na
még bővíthető hosszabb távon tehát nem
kategorizálnák értékkelem én nagyon az
ember tehát önmagába véve az embernek
van egy ér érték tehát nem szeretnék éen
szélsőségeket csak ugye viszont a
tényekről azért érdemes beszélni és
köszi hogy ilyen módon attá erre
lehetőséget mert az áldozatok ahogy ott
vannak mellettük tehát rengetegen
áldozatokká válnak és ezért jó hogy be
van hozva egy-egy ilyen beszélgetés akár
hogy hátha egy mondatból vagy egy
mondattal tovább lehet az úton haladni
ha nincs ott az a morzsa egy idő után
csak rájövök hogy vajon érdemes-e akkor
még remélni hogy legyen valami belőle
többletút képződ é úgymond igen hát még
egy két mintát felhoznék és akkor utána
átmegyünk erre a pont erre aaró beszélni
hogy miben reménykedhetünk pontosan az
egyik amit láttam az az hogy nem ismerik
az alapelveket a nárcisztikus személyek
habár használják és ez ez a navigátor
podcast is hogyha valaki megnézi a az
intrót pont erről szó hogy léteznek
alapelvek léteznek olyan alapelvek amik
mindent mozgatnak és függetlenül attól
hog hogyan cselekszünk mármint hogy hogy
a cselekedeteinknek a a kimenetelét nem
tudjuk befolyásolni mi el tudjuk dönteni
hogy valamit cselekszünk-e vagy nem de
ha alapelvek ellen cselekszünk
előbb-utóbb valahogy vissza fogz ütni
számunkra na most egy nárcisztikus
személy nem hiszi hogy léteznek
alapelvek ő úgy gondolja hogy ő képes
arra hogy manipulálja a környezetét úgy
ahogy szeretné és nem fog ez visszaütni
tehát ez egy mély arrogancia
benne viszont használja az alapelveket
tehát hogy azt mondja hogy egy
nárcisztikus személy hogy ebben a
családban ezen túl így fogunk csinálni
mert ez az alapelv és mond egy alapelvet
és tegyü fel jól is hangzik akár a
bibliából is elővesz egy idéz eg egy
igerészt és és azt mondja hogy ezért és
akkor a bibliát használja valamilyen de
viszont amikor megszegi akkor a többiek
úgy állnak hogy saját alapelvedet tehát
most mondtad két hettel ezelőtt hogy
hogy hogy ezt ezt így fogjuk csinálni
mostantól és ilyenkor a nárcisztikus fé
azt mondja hogy igen de ez kivétel amit
most én csináltam ez azért kivétel és
akkor mond még egy másik szabályt cs
akkor megjegyzi a család hogy
hogy például most mondj konkrét példát
valamit kitalálok azért hogy hogy
lehessen belekapaszkodni azt mondja a
nárcisztikus személy hogy ebben a
családban este 10 után nem nézünk tévé-t
mert a tv az rossz a szemnek és akkor a
az emberek akik már meg szerették volna
nézni befejezni azt a műsort akkor akkor
na úgy vannak vele naagó hát akkor akkor
ez a szabály ehhez fogjuk tartani na de
egy hét múlva pont a a a nárcisztikus
személy az aki pont nézi a tévét és
akkor azt mondják hogy hol hol hol mi
itt a szabály és akkor azt mondja a nárc
igen de a kivétel az amikor választások
vannak most jönnek a meg kell egy egy
egy egy jól felkészült állampolgár
bocsánat egy állampolgár jól fel van
készülve és tudja hogy a választásoknak
a a na jó oké akkor akkor tudjuk hogy ez
a szabály hogy vannak olyan események
amelyekre fel kell készülni rendben de a
legközelebb még egyszer megszegi a saját
szabályát és már úgy van a fejünkben
hogy van egy szabály aminek van egy
kivétele aminek van még egy kivétele és
akkor valójában egy idő után azt se
tudod hogy mi is a szabály pontosan
fogalmam sincs mi a szabály egyszerűen
azt tudom hogy akármit csinálok kapok a
fejemre egyet és akkor a után már nem is
tudom megjegyezni a szabályrendszert már
el is hagyom az egészet és és azt mondom
oké akkor mondd meg mit csináljak mondd
meg hánykor keljek hánykor feküdjek mit
viseljek mit egyek mit gondoljak mit
olvassak és és így lehet gyakorlatilag
valakinek az ön beccsülését a porig
zúzni pontosan többször tapasztalom én
is ezt és úgy szoktak fogalmazni hogy
kettősség tehát egyik nap állít valamit
és rá nem tudom mennyi időre hiába hogy
ő úgymond a családnak a feje vagy a
döntéshozó vagy a bármi bemegyünk
szívesen akár dolgoznunk össze vele de
hogy rá öt napra ő maga a saját maga
által felállított szabályrendszert
elsőként szegi meg meg tehát ide ismét
visszaemelem azt hogy a
nyomonkövethetőségnek a hiánya tehát
mond valami nagyot valami alapot amitő
le függ amit ő határoz meg de tényleg ő
az első aki megszegi és nem érzi a
súlyát annak hogy megszegte tehát ez a
fájó és ugye a környezete ezért buokik
ki hogy nincsen ott a következmény tehát
hogyhogy nem érzi a súlyát és emlékszem
valaki egyszer úgy fogalmazott hogy deed
itt hogy lehet az hogy hideg empátia
hogy lehet az empátiát a hidegséggel
társítani mertogy az empátia az mégis
csak úgy meleg tehát hogy az valahogy
ahhoz társítódik hozzá hogy az meleg de
hogy mégis ugye ez a nyomon követhetőség
meg hogy lavírozások vannak tényleg ezt
generálják hogy nem érzem a súlyát annak
hogy mi a tetteknek a következménye
tehát nincsen a felelősségvállalás jelen
és ez is repeszti szét a mellette lévőt
és a működést
igen az utolsó dolog amit behoznék mint
technika és utána aztán átér ünk a a
megoldásra egy kicsi fény is jöjjön ebbe
az adásba pontosan
az az az hogy nincs teljesítménye egy
nárcisztikusnak és ezt főleg biznisz
körülmények között lehet a legjobban
lemérni hogy ameddig nincs teljesítménye
akkor amikor nem látja senki amikor
látja láthatóvá válik akkor ő az első
aki beleszól elmondja a véleményét
prominens határozót kompetens képet
alkot magáról
és és az az érzésed hogy na ez ez ez ez
egy tuti ő ő őt vezetőnek kéne
választani mert mindenről tudja a van
egy határozott véleménye nem is
kételkedik magáb erőteljes ha kell
szembeszáll a a és és sokszor jó
dolgokat is mond tehát nem nem azt
mondom hogy sok egységeket mond egy
nárcisztikus hanem sokszor sokszor okos
és nagyon jól meg tudja fogni a lényegét
egy problémának és jönnek javaslatokkal
és ötletekkel és tervekkel viszont
amikor már magukra maradnak én ezt már
konkrétan tapasztaltam is amikor magukra
maradnak és senki nem látja őket abbon a
pillanatban elszivárog a teljesítmény
mert nem nézi senki őket valójában ott
már a belső fegyelemre kéne hagyatkozni
amire ami ami nincs mert nem kultiválta
magába a belső fegyelmet és ez a fajta
érdekes kettősség hogy hogy a
teljesítmény elmarad amikor láthatatlan
viszont mindig van véleménye ez
valójában megint egy gázlángozási
manőver mert olyan minthogyha azt adná
el hogy a terv az a lényeg ha megvan a
terv az a 95% már csak meg kell csinálni
viszont ez nem igaz a világunk nem így
működik a terv a kisebbik rész és a meg
kell csak csinálni az a 95% valójában a
háttérben a csendes szorgalmas alázatos
emberek azok akik működtetik a
világunkat és a komplex terveket ők
viszik végig és és ez a fajta ez a fajta
manipulatív trükk amikor amikor azt
mondja hogy hát a tervvel előjöttem már
elkezdtem már a papírok alá vannak írva
már a folyamatok el vannak indulva ez
valójában úgy felnagyítja minth hogyha
ez lenne a fő dolog és valójában a
teljesítmény mögötte elmarad és elbukik
ez az egész és utána persze kiáll és azt
mondja hogy hát de emberek én elkezdtem
és már el volt indítva már csak meg kell
csinálni már még ő még büszke is magára
de ez egy manipuláció a háttérben nem
csak meg kell csinálni hanem a terv már
csak megvan de most jön az igazi munka
ahol viszont te nem tetted oda a
csontodat mert nem látott senki nem
tudom ezt tapasztaltad-e igen és érdekes
módon több felőlről is megközelíteném
egyik oldal az lenne hogy igen
tapasztaltam és ha valaki az általa
bedobott tervet véghez viszi ő a részét
nem teszi oda de a dicsőségnek a
kaszorúját learatja ő magának tudja be
ez nekem köszönhető tudjátok mert én
voltam az aki de nem arra fókuszál hogy
ki volt aki várra vette és vitte és
támogatta és kimunkálta tehát magának
tudja be a dicsőséget egyik gondolat ez
jutott eszembe a másik meg az hogy
ajándékaink mindannyiunknak vannak és
olyan érdekes ahogy a bibli hozza azt
hogy nem azt mondja hogy ajándékairól
ismeritek meg őket hanem gyümölcseikről
ismeritek meg őket és ezt itt
szétválasztanám tehát lehet ajándék és
tényleg megfigyelhető akikkel én
beszélek
áldozatokkal meg annyiszor elmondják
olyan intellektuális olyan nagy
szaktudása van olyan pozíciókat tölt be
hogy hatalmasakat de hogy mégis tehát
így hirtelen egy nagy felhevülés tehát
ugye valahogy van egy ilyen kis
közmondás talán így hangzik hogy nagyobb
a füstje mint a lángja vagy valahogy így
érted tehát igen ez van hogy a füst ott
van de hogy a láng ége végig hogy
tudokén cselekvőleni tudom azt a
folyamatot véghez vinni ezzel
egészíteném
ki azt hiszem hogy kicsit kifújhatunk
mert most a toikus ez egy befeszüléses
rész volt én is ezt érveztem végig
komolyan hogy nehéz téma nehéz téma az
az igazság még van egy-két dolog amit de
most most egy kicsit azt hiszem hogy
most már úgyis már mindjárt ott vagy a
másfél óránál nem akarok megállni másfél
óránál mer egy picit menjünk tovább
azért hogy hogy legyen egy kicsi
remélysugár is pontosan itt van valaki
azt mondja hogy rendben meggyőztetek
kezdem felismerni hogy a testvérem
édesapám édesanyám a főnököm a
munkatársam egy nárcisztikus személy
amúgy nem lehet ezekről eleget beszélni
tehát hogy ha még a hallgatóknak
kedvéérő hogyha ezt még két órán
keresztül kéne folytatni én még tudnám
sorolni így a mintákat és a példákat
ezzel kapcsolatban talán még fogjuk is a
kommentek alapján fog majd eldönteni
érdemes-e erről tovább
beszélgetni mit kezdhet valaki aki rájön
arra hogy benne van egy valamilyen
nárcisztikus
toxikus bántalmazó kapcsolatban és lehet
nyilván most az egyik válaszod az lehet
hogy a kontextustól függ tehát hogy de
tegyük fel most vegyük az egyik példát
ami hogy a szülő
nárcisztikus több ilyennel találkoztam
is a annyira elszenvedői a gyerekek
ennek a működésnek valahogy úgy
fogalmaznék hogy a
felnőttségüket gátolják meg a felnőtté
való válásukat gátolják meg amiket én
így láttam meg megtapasztaltam ami
működőképes volt hogy szigorított
keretfelépítés tehát szigorított
határfelépítés egy kicsit már ez a
határokozás olyan klisés úgy valahogy na
azt érzékelem hogy na nincs akkora ereje
de hogy mégis ez a határ felé építés meg
a
keretfelépítés fájó másik felől azt
látni hogy úgy fogalmaztak hogy edit
akkor elterveztem hogy egy héten ezután
fölhívom háromszor nem
13szor de az a három hívásom is amivel
tele van tüzdelve na nem is vagyok
fontos neked tegnap előtt se hívtál
tegnap se hívtál várhatom hogy hívjál
nem jelentek semmit neked és elindul
megint egy folyamat hogy ennyi te te te
most így vagy te így állsz ezt csinálod
az any vagy ezt csinálod az apádda
történetesen pedig mi neveltünk fel
pedig mi neveltünk föl és tudod hogy
annak idején hogy mennyi áldozatot és
mennyit vírasztottam melletted és mit
tettem és iskoláztattalak és tudod ezek
így megvannak nagyon intenzíven tehát én
mindenképp ezt egyik megoldásnak látom
hogy a keretekhez való
ragaszkodás amikor vádlással jön felé a
szülő a gyerek felé tehát a vádlást én
egy picit úgy képzelem mint egy olajat
mint az olajat ami már be van gyújtva
hogyha arra a tűzre ami már éget valamit
aminek lenyomata van évek óta ha még
odaatöltöm az én részemet az még jobban
lángra kap tehát én azt mondom hogy
valahogy bölcsen megragadni azt hogy
kivonulni abból a kontextusból ami
adatott amit érzékelek tehát lehet
esetleg egy empátiával validálni oké
megértelek hogy ne legyen az a rideg
frigid magatartás de hogy mennyire
megyek bele abba hogy megértelek és
elkezdek érzelmileg kapcsolódni mert
ugye itt a tiszteld az apádat és az
anyádat alapáv azért mégis csak tehát az
attól független hogy ő milyen
működésű olyan érdekes nemrég olvastam
azt egy helyen hogy a tisztelt apádat és
anyádat egy picit valahol úgy volt
magyarázva hogy hát tanulj belőle ezzel
is összefüggésbe hozható nem tudom ilyen
érdekes kis kiemelést egy ilyen
magyarázatot olvastam is hogy tanulj
belőle tehát tanul tulj abból hogy a
velük való viszonyodat hogyan tudod
fönntartani vagy tanulj abból az adott
helyzetből amit eddig már átéltél egy
picit ezt így folytatom és hogyha a
szülőgyerekkapcsolatot nézem talán egy
alap lehet az is hogy ti szülők vagy ti
apák ne ingereljétek a ti gyermekeiteket
tehát ezt ha fordítottan visszaviszem ha
kap egy ingerlést a gyerek felnőttként
vagy folyamatosan kapott tehát van az a
pont ahol már én vállalhatom a felelős
éget arra nézve hogy nem tehetem ki
magamat hogy
ingerő áldozat vagy ingerelhető áldozat
legyek mert éltetek ezzel egy dinamikát
tehát újból meg újból egy játszmának a
részese leszek tehát a játszmát csak
akkor lehet leállítani hogyha az egyik
fél kilépik belőle a játszmák azok tal
mond hogy engedjük el a fülünk mellett
ezeket a sértéseket van amikor ez a
legoptimálisabb megoldás mert ugye itt
volt szó a gázlángozásról volt szó a a
szósalátázásról ezeket ide mind mind
mind beemelhetjük újból vagy a
befeketítési struktúrákról vagy a
becsmérlési struktúrákról akár igen van
az a pont amikor csak ebben tudok
megállni és szilárdan állni hogy oké
reagálsz de hogy én nem tudok erre
reagálni mert érdemben nem tudok
kollaborálni tehát emlékszem voltak
mondatok amiket valahogy így tudtunk
átbeszélni vagy így tudtunk megragadni
ha érdemben nincs ahogy kapcsolódni vagy
szintekben nincs ahogy kapcsolódni tehát
é hiába kérem a nárcisztikus anyától
vagy apától vagy rokontól vagy bárkitől
hogy kérlek érts meg nézd nekem ezek az
érzéseim ugye minden
megkérdőjeleződik tehát egy idő után már
szükséges hogy önmagam önmagam részét
vállaljam be tehát érette nem
vállalhatok többet csak azt hogy a
háttérben valamelyest ott vagyok ameddig
azt érzékelem hogy ott lehetek s ide
megint visszahozom a józon ott létet
vagy a józan rálátási attitűdöt akár egy
picit más kontextusba helyezve
igen még talán egy példát hoznék be nem
tudom még milyen kérdés lenne lehet hogy
a következőhöz akár a példán jobban
találna egy jézusi igen mondanám kösz
szépen nem is vártam el hogy tudd de
köszi oké tehát jézusnak a magatartása
akkor amikor szembesített egy bizonyos
réteget egy csoportot azzal hogy ők hol
állnak vagy hogy vannak vagy bármi tehát
volt egy réteg aki
felgerjedt és annyira fel erjed hogy meg
akarták őt kövezni tehát akarták
igazából bántalmazni és olyan érdekes
mert hogy ott annyira értelmetlen lett
volna hogy ők a bántalmazónak jézus maga
kitegye magát a bántalmazók
bántalmazásának hogy ott nem lett volna
érdemes azt a folyamatot véghez vinni
mert ő nem azért jött hogy egy ilyen
értelmetlen szenvedésnek legyen a
részese hanem egy értelmesnek valahol a
későbbiekben tehát nem úgy jött el vagy
nem az volt az ő órájának a
beteljesedési folyamata vagy a
kicsúcsosodási folyamata hogy akkor
engem a tömeg megkövez és hagyom magam
pedig ugye nagyon sok keresztény
félreértelmezi tehát akkor
keresztényként tűrjünk megszenvedjünk de
nem volt ez kérve vagy nincs ez kérve
meg hogy nincs is ez bemutatva tehát ő
ott mit tesz átvonul a tömegen kisétál
és ottgyja a tömeget tehát van amikor
nem megy a kollaborativitás tehát van
amikor szükséges kisétálnom is é úgy
néznem vissza hogy ez nem az az óra ez
most nem az én órám ez nem az a rész
amit én lenne szükséges hogy emeljek
vagy tovább vigyek nem tudom nekem ez
annyira nagy bölcsességet meg úgy
rálátást ad arra hogy az értelmes meg az
értelmetlen szenvedés között meg a
reflexiók között különbséget tenni és
ugye egy picit visszaemelem ezt a kulcot
hogy keresztényként milyen gyakran
megragadjuk azt ó hát tűrők hát de jézus
is ugye a türelmet akár hogyha az egyik
arcodat megütik fordítsd oda a másikat
is tehát ez nem úgy szükséges értelmezni
hanem azt hogy nem kell provokálni tehát
nincs mit visszaűd meg hogy visszavágj
és újból egy boxmeccsbe keveredjetek
bele vagy keveredjünk bele mert az csak
egy provokatív tényező tehát újból olaj
a tűzre ráöntött olaj ami újból egy nagy
lángot egy nagy sercegést fog hozni
tehát ezt így beemelném mindenképp ühüm
de ez ez abszolút rezonál azzal amit
amúgy ramanié is javasolt hogy soha ne
konfrontálódjunk egy nárcisztikussal egy
teljesen értelmetlen úgy írta le mint
egy iszap birkózást hogy a végén iszapos
leszel abszolút tehát hogy belemész a
mocsárba és ő élvezni fogja tehát a
negatív töltetű energia és energia
számára és hogyha belemész az ő játékai
szerint játszani a végén csak az lesz
hogy összevisszaatöröd magad és nem
fogod tudni a másik szemét legyőzni
megváltoztatni az igazodat ki harcolni
sehogy se pontosan pontosan é ugye
belevesz egy akár egy reaktív
agresszióba tehát az ő szintjére levisz
és akkor utólag nekem bűntudatom lesz
vagy nekünk bűntudatunk lesz akár attól
hogy mi aúóért mentem bele és köszöni
szépen ő ezt amúgy se érzi érted és amit
érzékelek tehát ezt a kulcszót behoznám
ide hogy csatavesztettség tehát előre
látható csatavesztettség hogy belemenni
egy konfrontációba tehát nem érti volt
olyan hogy én is próbálkoztam hogy
elmagyaráztam hogy etikai alapelvekbe
hoztam így konkrét tényezőket
megmagyarázván
egy bizonyos működés kapcsán és
egyszerűen minden de minden így vissza
lett fordítva hogy igen de te hogy te
azt teszed mert érted tehát nem
csatavesztettség ezt a kulcszót hoznám
ide be röviden tömören ühüm amúgy
tapasztalsz különbséget
egy nárcisztikus anya és egy
nárcisztikus apa között tehát amikor a
feminin nárcizmus megjelenik és a
maszkulin
nárcizmus talán úgy fogalmaznék hogy az
anya
még inkább ott tartja mondhatni az
uralma alatt a gyermekeit tehát ez az
ödipuszi igen igen igen mindenképp ez a
fajta igen és amit kiemelek ezzel
kapcsolatosan hogy annyira nagy
táplálékforrás a gyermek hogy a gyerek
már ott van 40 éves és még mindig
táplálja az anyát tehát jobban ráülnek a
rendszer a gyerekre jobban ráülnek a
gyerekek működésére én ezt érzékelem
ugye nem is hiába van az hogy az anyós
történetek tehát óriási tehát oggy
kiugrik ez az egés azért teljesen két
különböző mintázat mert egy grandiózus
náci ikus apa gyakran például bántalmazó
elutasító de viszont egy anya pont az
aki gyere meg bigaszt maradthon min
kötöz elont pontosan tehát egyik a
távolságtartó kintre helyezlek az apa az
anya meg a bentre helyezlek maradj itt a
fészkedbe miért van ugye ez a bumeráng
effektus vagy a mama hotel ezzel is
mostanságb van ilyen sokat fogalmazva
vagy foglalkozva igazából mert hogy az
ott tartottság tehát ott növekedik a
szárnyakalacs az a biztonság h
látszólagos biztonság az anyának de a
gyereknek persze hogy nem az üüm nézzünk
egy másik ilyen kapcsolatot például a
főnökünk tehát egy főnök alkalmazott
viszonyában megjelenik ez a nárcizmus
milyen gondolatait milyen tanácsokat
tudnál adni ebben az az esetben hogy
hogyan bánjunk egy főnökkel amelyik
nárcisztikus én amit érzékeltem hogy a
főnökök direkten nem konfrontálnak tehát
ide visszahozom azt a szó hogy
udvarnokok
vagy az udvartartásából valakit elővesz
megbízza hogy ezzel a személlyel ezzel
az alkalmazottal azt az ügyet rendez le
önmagukat feltüntetik jó színbe és az
udvarnok a azt a részt ami a nehéz rész
leviszi vagy levezetődik rajta és hogyha
nem jó lesz a
végkifejlett akkor az udvarnokon kér is
számon úgymond tehát hosszú áll rajta
hogy te nem jól végezted pedig én
megbíztam benned én téged megbíztalak
ezzel és ugye ide behozza a pszichológia
azt a kifejezést is hogy repülő majmok
tehát magának igen repülő majmokat tart
fönn és vannak mindig
ilyen nagyon durva kifejezés tehát úy
sír a lelkem egyik felől hogy emberekre
vagy működésükre nézve van ez kimondva
működésse nem emberekre semmikép tehát
ezt nagyon abszolút tehát nagyon
kiemelem mert nagyon szeretem az
emereket nagy nagyon úgyhogy nem
bántanám semmiképp hogy ugye ezek a
repülő majmok elvégzik a piszkos munkát
elvégzik a rájuk bízott munkát de nem az
van hogy a nárcisztikus aspektusú főnök
válom veregeti hogy jól van derék és
hűszolgám most érd jól hanem az van hogy
még inkább számonkér és elégedetlen és
újból meg újból fenntart egy olyan
dinamikát ami őket odakapcsolja mert az
ígérgetések a nagy nem tudom
megláttatások hogyha cselekvő vagy akkor
nézdé mivel jutalm mazlak tehát
megvannak azok a kis madzagok amivel
újból meg újból vissza tudja őket is
akár
porszívózgatni hát ez egy ez egy nagyon
érdekes minta mert talán akkor magunkon
is felismerhetünk ilyen mintákat hogy én
mikor váltam repülőmajommá mert az is
lehet hogy én is valakinek az áldozata
tehát hogy nem gondolkoztam rajta csak
te hogy mit mit tanácsolál hogy hogyan
ismerje fel valaki magában hogy
valamelyik kapcsolatban ő repülő majommá
vált például hogyha tegyük föl egy
alkalmazott odamegy a főnök köz hogy
beszéljen vele maradunk a főnökös
példánál megengedett odamegy az
alkalmazott direkten beszélni vele és
azt mondja a főnök tehát kibukik
áttolja rá
befeketítő módon ezt a stratégiát
alkalmazva hogy veled annyi baj van sa a
tegnap előtt is és a múltkor is és
valahol így is fogalmazhatnék nagyon
durva megfogalmazást tehát a
csicskájaként néz rá arra az
alkalmazottra amikor van egy ilyen
lenyugvásib fázis viszont csak
befejeződik ott az a folyamat de úgy
hogy már nem ő kontaktál vele hanem
odajön be a repülő majomnak a szerepe
tehát amikor annyira elmérgesedik a
helyzet akkor kezdi el
alkalmazni azt hogy akkor valakit oda be
kell tegyek önmagam helyett mertogy
vigye el a hátán x a szenvedést és én
aztán majd learatom a talért ha learatom
s ha nem akkor őt fogom bántalmazni
azért aki nem jó munkát végzett az a az
a repülő maajmot tehát honnan lehet
felismerni hogyha direkt be volt
kommunikál val a főnökkel és nem én
vagyok a főnöke annak az alkalmazottnak
tehát ez egy nagyon jó ismertetőjel hogy
miért nekem lenne szükségem arra hogy
elvégezzem ezt a munkát amit neked
közöltek vagy fájdalmat osztottak meg
veled hogy valami nem jól működik tehát
valahol azt érzékelem hogy a
játszmatáncban nem
lehetne vagy nem szabadna hogy partnerek
legyünk tehát kivel volt megbeszélve
tehát az eredeti történet
hogyan volt felvezetve vagy hogyan volt
megélve egy történetbe húznak minket én
szereplőt pontosan pontosan
mellékszereplőt
igen pontosan kiemelném de hogy hogy
hogy ha felismerjük hogy mi mit is
keresek ebbe a történetbe és egyáltalán
megyek és csinálom valakinek a munkáját
de én mint mellékszereplő valahog azt
mondja tegyük fel ilyenkor a főnök hogy
hát ez ez ez ez az alkalmazott ez ez
szemtelen egyfolytában késik
fizetésemelé kér és és gyakorlatilag így
elkezd manipulálni hergelni és akkor egy
idő után valaki meg kéne mondja ennek a
szemé k hogy hogy el van tévve na és így
így hagyja a történet és akkor én bennem
az van hogy valakinek lehet pont én kell
legyek hát milyen milyen ember vagyok ha
nem hallom meg a és akkor odamegyek és
elkezdem a másik te hát alig vagy itt
még két év ennél a cégnél már
fizetésemelést is akarsz kérni meg nem
na azért az a munka az amit elvégezt
éppen nem olyan mint amilyennek gondolod
és és a másik szemé azt mondja hát még
ez is jön hát még még ez is
ellenem beszél hát nem meg vagyok őrülve
vagy mi történik velem van a baj tehát
hogy így lehet például repülőmajommá
válni pontosan pontosan é úgy
fogalmaznék láttam ilyen effektusokat
hogy annyira egyensúlyvesztett állapot
alakul ki hogy az alkalmazott vagy
teljesen behódol de egy idő után
mentális és pszichés zavarok képződnek
nála vagy tényleg otth hagyja a céget
tehát jobb esetben otthgyja a céget mert
nem bírja meg annak a súlyát hogy ez az
effektus hogy ő nem tudod direktbe
kollaborálni hanem még rá volt erősítve
valakivel tehát egy egyensúlyvesztés
hogy most éír jol ketten vannak ellenem
tehát nem elég hogy van egy fájdalmam
még valaki oda van rendelve az én
főnököm mellé vagy oda rendelt az én
főnököm tehát nem direkt be é ugye itt a
személytelenség kulc szót is behoznám
hogy egy munkahelyen az az alap hogyha
ki van építve hogy lehet nekem személyes
problémám és merhetek-e beszélni róla
vagy ha beszélek akkor jön egy ilyen
visszaélés ugye picit ide a
grandiozitással kapcsolatosan azt is
beemelném hogy abból is nagyon
felismerhető hogy ők a legjobbak tehát
senki más nincs olyan szinten mint ők és
bizonygatják is hogy ők a legjobbak
tehát én még nem hallottam olyan
grandioózitással működött hogy azt
mondja hogy elismerem annak az embernek
a munkáját és olyan nagyra tartom tehát
nincsen ott a partnerség és ugye miért
is van ez a fogalom hogy repülő maajom
mert nincs ott a partnerség tehát te
nekem tényleg az vagy egy eszköz akit én
most fel fogok használni és bizonyos
szempontból ezek a játszmái a
nárcisztikusnak személytelenek abszolút
abszolút történik akkor érdemes arra
gondolnunk hogy hogy ez olyan mintogyha
m az autó elüt minket vagy vagy valami
baleset történik hogy nem azért ütel
mert rossz ember
vagyok mert pont én vagyok ott és ha
tegyük fel valahogy megúszom és hátrább
lépek egy lépést észre fogom tudni
ugyanzt a dinamikát venni egy másik
személlyel szemben tegyük fel pont egy
másik repülőmajommal szemben aki szegény
azt hitte hogy hogy a jó úyért harcolt
és most pont ő lesz a következő
áldozat mi van akkor hogyha nem a
főnökünk tehát nem egy autoritá é azt
mondom személy szerint hogy ha
észreveszed hogy a főnököd nárcisztikus
készítsd a cvédet készülj mert egyrészt
könnyebb lesz elviselni a az abúzust
hogyha készülsz és van egy b terved és
amikor felkészültél menj mert mert ez
nem fog változni és egyre rosszabb lesz
de mi van akkor hogyha munkatársad az ez
egy másik tehát nem vagy alárendelve
neki bizonyos szempontból nem az
autoritás nem a fölötted levő autoritás
az aki aki ez ilyet is láttam többször
is és olyan durva a pszichoszomatikus
tünetekben nyilvánul meg hogy olyan is
volt hogy elmondta hogy ahogy bemegy az
irodába úgy beáll a szorongás úgy beáll
a gyomorideg hogy amíg ki nem jön onnan
végig ott van az a gyomorideg állapot és
teljes leuralást és teljes kontrollt
érzékel na ugye itt egy picit nem akarok
nagy szavakat használni merthogy nem
olyan egyszerű sokszor a helyzet
megkérdőjelezni vagy feltenni a kérdést
önmagunk szám mára hogy mit ad nekem ez
a munkahely ad annyit nyújt annyit hogy
itt tudjak maradni ezekkel a
helyzetekkel együtt is akár ennek a
helyzetnek az ellenére is mert ugye itt
nagyon nemelem hogy nem lehet zöld ágra
vergődni hogy egy picit ezt a gondolatot
ideemeljen be és nincsen megegyezés
nincsen az hogy most mi akkor kötöttünk
egy szövetséget egy kollegális
szövetséget is közöljük egymással négy
szem közt és ugye akár igik az igét is
hogyha beemelem ide hogy ha valakivel
valami gondod van akkor jelez neki
négyszem közt de nem lehet ezt jelezni
mert hogyha négys szem közt jelezve van
mivel nincs meg az az empátiás kisség
ugye rögtön az első reakció hogy
befeketíti azt aki elkezdett felé
jelzéseket adni és utána az a személy
jön ki rosszul a helyzetből mert olyan
technikák meg taktikákkal van játszva
hogy úgyis az marad alul aki őszintén
igazságosan odatette volna magát és
akarta az építkez vagy a jó jövőnek az
építését vagy a kollegális kapcsolat
építését amit egy picit hogyha
megengeded egy kicsit a főnök
gondolathoz lépek vissza tehát általában
azt a dinamikát is úgy érzékelni lehet
hogy a főnök vagy a vezető pozícióban
lépők azokat az embereket eltávolítják
maguktól akik igazságot vinnének be abbó
a
kapcsolatrendszerbe nem bírják meg azt
maguk körül amúgy az egy általános
tendencia én azt látom amivel el lehet
üldözni nárcisztikust az a magas
önbecsülés absol abszolút tehát nem tud
mit kezdeni a magas önbecsülésű
emberekkel tehát annyira kiüti a
biztosítékot kontrollvesztettséget él
meg és nagyon durván reagál tehát
arrogánsan fölényesen ugye ezzel az
empátia nélküliséggel tehát mindent
mindent kézben tartva tehát egy félelem
rejtőzik olyankor mögötte mert mi lesz
hogyha hatalomvesztett leszek és ugye a
hatalomvesztettségérzés pont itt jön elő
ha valakinek magas az önbecsülése nem
megvezethető a kollegális kapcsolatnál
ugyanezt látom amúgy adott pont hogy
felmérni a helyzetet hogy nyújt nekem
annyit mert lehet hogy valaki
szenvedélyesen szereti a szakmáját és
azt mondja h nekem annyira jó minden
feltétel nagyon adott hát akkor hogy
oldja meg hát mégis csak jó lenne
maradni ugye esetleg optimális megoldás
lehet az én olyat is hallottam most
kinél hogy adatot meg vagy hogyan lehet
ezt kivitelezni hogy akkor kérte hogy
hát lehetne-e hogy külön egy kicsi
sarkot nekibe rendezni egy kicsi irodát
csak egy kicsi kuckót leválasztani
mertogy én annyira szeretem de valahogy
mégse tudok kiegyezni ezzel a a
kollégával tehát vannak módszerek én úgy
gondolom na de igen én még azt
tanácsolnám ilyen szempontból
praktikusan hogy jegyezz le mindent
tehát hogy hogy legyen egy jegyzőkönyved
mert egyrészt a gázlángozás miatt a
tagadni fogja a realitásodat
ezerféleképpen mentsd el az emmaileket
mentsd el az üzeneteket gyűjtsd a
bizonyítékokat és és ne konfrontálój
abszolút tehát nem a kollégával
konfrontálni hanem a vezető elé vinni az
összegyűjtött anyagot a kellő
pillanatban bölcsességgel mindenképp egy
nagy bölcsessége alázattal mert ugye itt
nem az a cél hogy kiellengérezni bárkit
is mert hogy ugye az etikai alapelveket
veszem tehát nem ez a cél hanem az hogy
hogy lehetne építkezni mindennek
ellenére ami itt van na mert hogy itt
amúgy adott ponton ugye a pszichés
egészség megőrzéséről meg a mentális
éépség megőrzéséről van szó igen ez így
van meg a magasönbecsülésnél most
akartam egy példát mondani hogy hogy
miért tehát hogy h hogyan működik egy
magas önbecsülésű személyi nárcisztikus
mellett nagyon érdekes a dinamika tegyük
fel most éppen beszélgetünk egy
ugyancsak egy nem tudom egy ilyen
vacsoránál és akkor odajön egy
nárcisztikus személy és azt mondja fú
milyen autóm van te milyen autót vettem
nemrég és akkor elkezdi maga fele
terelni a beszélgetést amúgy ez egy
tipikus minta hogy előbb-utóbb mindig
róla kezdünk el beszélni és valahogy
áttereli és akkor egy magasön beccsülési
személy azt mondja hogy hm tényleg
szuper lehet az autód na de mit is
mondtál akkor legközelebb is visszatér a
másik személyhez és ezt megcsinálja vagy
négyszer ötször a másik személy hogy
visszapróbálja magára terelni a
figyelmet és anélkül felmérgelődni v
anélkül hogy hogy megszégyenítenéd a
másik személyt mindig visszatereled az
eredeti témát és ott hagy és ott hagy
abban a pillanatban egyszerűen nem bírja
nem bírja hogy nem ne róla szóljon az ő
sérelmeiről vagy az ő győzelmeiről az ő
szexuális sikereiről vagy az ő
mindenféle tehát hogy tehát kisétál
abból a kapcsolódásból mert nem talál
megértő fülekre igazából és neml bírja
ezt elviselni ha nem ő van a
középpontban és olyan érdekes hogy mit
éltetünk tehát azzal hogyha belemegyünk
az áldozatszerepbe pont ezt éltetjük
hogy ennek van hozama hogy te örökké
magadról beszélsz fenntartom azt a
helyzetet vagy a helyzetet megteremtem
megágyazok annak hogy tudjál magadról
beszélni tehát egy éltető forrás adott
ponton ugye úgy is nevezi a szakma hogy
nárcisztikus üzemanyag tehát ha éltetek
valamit ha táplálok valamit neki
üzemanyagforrás tud lenni az amivel én
tápl álom vagy igen a működésből igen
tehát az utolsó ilyen minta márm
bocsánat ilyen ilyen n kapcsolati
mintázat az az a házastársi kapcsolat mi
van hogyha felismerem hogy a férjem vagy
a feleségem nárcisztikus
általában amit érzékeltem ezzel
kapcsolatosan hát szerintem a
legnehezebb ebből a kapcsolódásból
kivonulni tehát évekig évekig valami
megy és egyszer jön a felismerés nem az
első két év alatt sz szokott jönni vagy
az első öt év alatt hanem évek mennek le
úgy és ugye ahogy az évek telnek a
rigolyák meg a belénk égett hatások is
erősödnek az idős korral együtt ugye
olyan érdekes hogy a biblia is úgy
széttagolja hogy a balgatag és a
bölcsesség idősek a bölcsességget
hordozó időseknek a kategóriája úgymond
nagyon nehéz ezt a dinamikát
megszüntetni megannyiszor a legtöbb
vajudást ilyen esetben láttam amikor
házas sak és gyerekek vannak jelen tehát
valahogy úgy fogalmaznék hogy mintha a
gyerekek vére tudom hogy nagyon erős
megfogalmazás de hogy tényleg sajnos ezt
így érzékelni lehet többször is
érzékelni több kapcsolódáson keresztül
is érzékelni lehet akár tehát a gyerekek
vére mintha áldozatként kiáltana most
érd jól tehát annyira az egész családi
dinamika vagy az egész családi rendszer
családtagok áldozatok lesznek de mégis
ugye ott van a a hölgyben legtöbb
esetben az hogy jó lenne
kimozdulni van egy ilyen kulcszó hogy
gazdasági függőség hogy gazdaságilag
függö kötőle és hogyan fogom eltartani a
gyermekeimet hogyha kimozdulok és mi
lesz hogyha ott kezd engem gázlángozni
és hogy ennek nagyon nagy a súlya tehát
egyik amit így talán mondanék hogy van-e
elég segítői rokoni szál vagy háttér aki
ebből a gazdasági pontosan ebből a
gazdasági függőségből egy picit engem
fel tudna oldani akár ha valaki tudna
két szobát biztosítani mert lehet hogy
van olyan de amíg nincsen meg az úgy
szoktak fogalmazni meg annyiszor láttam
hogy de hová menjek keressek halbérletet
tél idején ennyi idő után a két kicsi
gyermekemmel vagy a két nagyobból hát
mit tegyek most ment el az egyik éppen
nem tudom hová mesterizni meg ilyenek
hát és egyik röpül ki a fészekből a
másik ép kamasz hogy lehet ezt a
dinamikát megszakítani tehát ennek
nagyon nagy a súja és sokszor ez a
kulszó hogy gazdasági függőség oda
kötődnek tehát nem is kötődés mert ugye
az egy egészséges valami hanem egy ilyen
dependens állapotot tart fön pont ebből
kifolyólag hogy nincsen az a
lefedezettség és ugye a grandiózus
nárcisztikussággal élő férfi még úgy
akár meg is fenyegeti hogy hát akkor
semmit nem kapsz te ki vagy semmit nem
csinálsz senki vagy ebben a kapcsolatban
mit tudsz felmutatni nézd én mennyit
letettem az
asztal pontosan és fenntartja ezzel azt
a dependenciát és ugye mivel már 20 év
van tegyük föl mögöttük vagy 10 év mit
tesz a nő visszanézz és arra gondol hát
tényleg igaza van akkor jobb hogyha
benne maradok igen igen
hát e ez ezek tényleg sötét dolgok mert
ha gyerekek is ott vannak
akkor akkor fokozottan nehézzé válik és
mondhatja egy nő az hogy
ő nem akar elválni nem akar szétválni
pláne amíg a gyerekek kicsik tegyük fel
vallási okok miatt azt mondja a vállás
az nem egy opció
és pont téged is meg kérdezek ilyen
szempontból keresztény szemmel te hogy
látod ilyen szempontból hogy a válás az
egy opció amikor jézust kérdezik hogy a
válással kapcsolatosan mi a véleménye
ugye azt mondja hogy mózes a ti kemény
szívűségetek miatt tette ezt tehát
igazából van az a pont amikor a keményys
szívűség annyira megátalkodottan ott van
az egyénben vagy ott van a társban ott
van az emberben hogy van amikor nincsen
lehetőség tehát én nagyon szövetségpárti
vagyok számomra a házasság a kapcsolat a
házastársi kapcsolat a szent de van az a
pont amikor már ahogy abuzálva vannak
vagy ahogy nagyon súlyosan mélyen
bántalmazva vannak és elveszítették
önmagukat az egyének tehát van az a pont
amikor kékre zöldve verve akár
meglátván azokat a nyomokat igen ott azt
lehet kimondani hogy
lehet hogy az ott egy opció tudna lenni
mert ugye nem egy értelmetlen áldozatot
kér tőlünk az isten hanem egy értelmest
ha m plusz egyszer próbálkozás volt ha n
plusz egyszer az volt hogy tényleg újra
próbáltam kezdeni lehetőséget próbáltunk
adni és nem működött az a lehetőség van
az a pont amikor lehet hogy az én életem
beáldozása által tud csak működni akkor
jobb kivonulni és ugye ide a kemény
szívűség meg a megátalkodott szívűséget
tudnám behozni tehát nem tegyük fel a
fizikai abúzust nem nem jelenik meg ez
már már csúrolja a szadizmusnak a a
határát
és és most tegyük fel hogy azért
próbálom megnézni hogy melyik az a pont
amikor azt mondja a nő hogy nem válok-
el annyival nehezebb lenne az életem
annyival kényelmetlenebbé válna nem nem
akarok elválni hogy látod hogy hogyan
tud együttélni mégis két személy hogyan
tudsz együttélni egy nárcisztikus
férjjel aki folyamatosan nem fizikailag
hanem lelkileg bántalmaz amúgy
zárójelben mondom hogy szerintem talán
rosszabb a lelki bántalmazás mint a
fizikai bántalmazás mert mert a a
fizikai látható és lejár egy rövid idő
alatt mondjam úgy a a lelki viszont
folyamatosan tart folyamatosan szorít és
olyan minth hogyha valakit úgy folytanál
meg hogy mindig egy csak egy
milliméteret szorítasz rajta és és ez
nagyon nagyon-nagyon és amikor teegyik
fel már már ott van hal akkor kicsit
enged szóval mit tudnál tanácsolni annak
a személynek milyen technikát hogy hogy
túl tudja élni két gondolat jut eszembe
egyik az hogy megalkuvó vagyok vagy
kompromisszumkötő vagyok nagyon nagy a
különbség a kettő között ha megalkovó
vagyok áldozat lettem áldozattá váltam
kompromisszumot kötök próbálok kötni de
nem működik akkor eljön az a pont én úgy
gondolom hogy minden áldozat életében
eljön az a pont előbb-utóbb amikor már
annyira fáj hogy önmaga sebei az ő sebei
kiáltanak igazából helyreigazításért
vagy gyógyulásért valahogy így fogalm
znék tehát egyik felől
ugye behozom ide most a bosszú szót és
kicsit olyan kényes ez a terület hogy
erre is átevickélünk de hogy mégis csak
azt mondja az ige hogy enyém a bosszú
állás én majd megfizetek tehát van az a
rész amikor mi nem tudunk igazságot
szolgáltatni mert ilyen parányi az a
amit mi tudunk hozzátenni ehhez a
működéshez de hogy mégis az hogy az
istennek a kegyelme ott van és valahol
mégiscsak tudnának helyreigazodni vagy
helyre formálódni azok a ások ez a
remény csak ott van hiszem annál akinél
feltör a fájdalom tehát néha szükséges
ugye az a pont vagy azt a pontot
megvárni vagy az a pont elérkezik ahogy
már fogalmaztam hogy annyira fáj hogy
ott már az egyén mondja ki hogy nem
tudok többet megalkodni tehát ez így nem
tud tovább működni valahol ez a
felkiáltás vagy ez a sóhajtás létrejön
amikor ez létrejön akkor ő a megalkovó
pozíciótól elkezd egy kicsit távolodni
és úgy gondolom most így a ráhábi
út jut eszembe amikor kapott egy
kegyelmet ráháb az ő működésében ugye ő
mondjuk egy prostituált volt de hogy egy
másfajta aspektuson keresztül próbálom
ide behozni és a kegyelemvonalon
keresztül hogy senki nem gondolta volna
hogy ő megkapja a kegyelmet tehát a
háttérben a szenvedőknek a lelkében és a
szenvedők állapotát
megélőtt vagy hogy újra élők lelkében
történik valami és én meg vagyok
győzödve hogy ez a kegyelem ott van és
az engedi hogy tört ténjen az istennek a
kegyelme és amikor visszatérek egy picit
a gondolathoz a megalkuvástól a
kompromisszum készségig eljut de ott már
az önmagával való kompromisszum késségé
eddig és ne tovább ott már nem áldozat
tehát egy ideig lehet hogy úgy kezdődik
hogy a kompromisszumot próbálom a
társammal kötni de nem működik benne
maradok az áldozat szerepbe a megalkovó
szerepbe de amikor onnan eltávolodok és
annyira fáj hogy a sebem kiállt tehát
tátong az a seb é van ez tényleg vannak
ez ezek a pontok hogy a seb kiállt már
igazságtételért vagy gyógyulásért és
ugye ahogy mondja az ige is hogy
bekötözöm a te sebeidet bebalzsamozom a
test zúzódásaidat hát a zúzódás kiált
segélykiáltó hangja van segélykiáltásnak
a szava tükröződik minden zúzódás mögött
és ott van ez a pont hogy azt mondom
hogy most akkor magammal szembekötök egy
kompromisszumot ugye itt van az hogy az
én saját
felelősségvállalásom ott már hiába várom
hiába narrálok újra történeteket de majd
jobb lesz de majd jobb lesz lesz az
másként is tehát megállni és azt a
pontot megnézni egy évvel ezelőtt hol
voltunk öttel ezelőtt hol voltunk ahhoz
viszonyítva valami módosult-e valami
változott-e
igen é most ezt tudnám íg nagyjából igen
pont rákerestem valakire igen a azt
hiszem
hogy vinter éva igen ismerős a neve
nem lassan a végére értünk a
beszélgetésnek és ezzel akartam zárni
hogy milyen reménysugarat tudunk adni
ezeknek a személyeknek és te is
említettél egy jó pár dolgot min például
az hogy kompromisszumokat kötünk vagy
pedig
megalkuunk valójában áldozatokká válunk
vagy pedig önként vállalva vállaljuk azt
hogy ott maradunk és és ez ez a
keresztény út valójában az önként
vállalt szenvedésnek az útja hogyha
akármi is legyen az amit vállalunk az
önként legyen ne az áldozatai legyünk
ennek pontosan pontosan és én csak azt
tudom tanácsolni azoknak a hallgatóknak
akik akik most nagyon mélyen
elgondolkoztak hogy most mihez kezdjenek
ebbe a pillanatb hogy képezzék magukat
először is titokban anélkül hogy
megmondanák ezt nyilván a másik
személynek képezzék magukat nézzenek
utána győződjenek meg róla hogy tényleg
félreértették a helyzetet vagy pedig
vagy pedig jól látják és és minél több
időt töltenek el vele annál hagyják hogy
elmélyüdjen elmélyenjen ez a dolog és
hagyják hogy hogy hogy elég információ
jusson hozzájuk hogy megértsék hogy abol
vannak hol vannak mert nem biztos hogy
tudják az emberek hogy hol vannak milyen
helyzetben és amikor már elég tisztán
látják a helyzetet akkor akkor még van
egy csomó döntési lehetőség lassan itt
úgyis ha már valaki két évtizede benne
van egy ilyen kapcsolatban most egy-két
év ameddig készül amikor már nem áldozat
teljesen másképp fog eltelni reménnyel
fogja eltölteni és vannak lehetőségek
van lehetőség vannak technikák hogyan
lehet együtt élni például ilyen a szürke
sziklatechnika amit amit meg lehet
tanulni nagyon remek források is vannak
aki aki egy angol forrást szeretne
például tudom ajánlani dr ramaniit
számomra amúgy a magyar források közül
ez a winteriva is mind koroáltam nem
jutott eszembe a nevedet de ebbe a
pillanatban beugrott y ezért is
kérdeztem hogy vinterévát ismered-e hogy
vinteréa egy nagyon szimpatikus frappáns
10 perces videókat készít de rengeteg
más ilyen témában is nem tehát hogy hogy
rengeteg más személy van aki még
ugyanebben a témában
beszél nagyon jó könyvek vannak ezzel
kapcsolatban és egy idő után az
információk ismétlődnek egy idő után már
a mesterévé válhatunk ennek a és és
amikor észrevesszük ugyanezeket a
dinamikákat élőben miközben történik
velünk rájövünk arra hogy hopp ez
gázlángozás hopp ez szósaláta hopp ez
nem tudom akkor már és és tudjuk hogy ez
nem személyes hogy el kell engedjük a
fülünk mellett akkor könnyebb elengedni
és lassan elkezdjük az önbecsülésünket
építeni és és és elvonulni akkor amikor
amikor esetleg bántalmazhat na tegük fel
elkezd kiabálni gyorsan elmegyünk most
vannak olyan helyzetek amikor tényleg
annyira toxikus hogy egyszerűen nem
lehet
elvonulni javaslom azt hogy keressenek
meg egy pszichológust legyen valaki egy
személy aki nem ferde az életébe akiben
megbízhat aki aki visszareflektál és
akár menjen titokba pszichológushoz vagy
vagy vagy vagy vagy valahol kezdje el a
növekedést és egy
elég sok növekedés után egy eljön egy
olyan pillanat amikor amikor már igazi
dönté helyzet előtt fog tudni állni mert
lehet hogy ebben a pillanatban most
valaki hallja és az az érzés odamegy és
akkor azt mondja hogy rájöttem te
nárcisztikus vagy ez ezt nem ajánlom és
se a konfrontációt se a félkész
információkat nem felkészült még eléggé
az a személy tehát ez egy naív
hozzáállás lenne nekem se működött amúgy
a nyílt konfrontáció és és komoly
sebeket szereztem úgyhogy úgyhogy én azt
tudom tanácsolni hogy van kiút az
embereknek hogy ezek valóban méltatlan
helyzetek ha felismerted ezeket nem
veled van a baj nézd meg nézz körbe
tanulj képezd magad és legyél bátor
legyél bátor mert nem az a bátor aki nem
fél hanem az aki a félelmei ellenére is
tud cselekedni és hogy erre tudom
bátorítani az embereket hogy kezdjetek
el tanulni kezdjetek el fejlődni és egy
idő után már nem fogsz
félni pontosan az a gondolat
fogalmazódott meg bennem így ahogy az
informálódással kapcsolatosan bizztattad
az et a hallgatókat hogy az
információnak van egy hatalom jellege ez
a hatalom igazából tehát egy jó értelmű
hatalom tud segíteni
pontosanol abszolút tehát egy olyan
ráláttatást segít előre tolni az
utainkon hogy azt érzi az egyény hogy én
már többet nem szükséges hogy
dagonyázzak ebbe a sárba hanem kaptam
egy erőt egy erővel körbevett hatalmat
tehát belülről egy ilyen elhatalmasodás
érzés hogy eddig és ne tovább éy ugye a
másik irány hogy erőt kapok és az
információ mellett ugye a transzformáció
tehát az átalakulás az átformálódás
tehát nagyon jó az információ és nagyon
szuper hogy ez egy ilyen végszóként ide
bejött és mellé oda rendelem azt hogy az
elidőzésből jön az átváltozás és egy idő
után átalakulások tudnak jönni tehát
mindennek van egy ilyen mélygyökérvert
hatása ah mi elidőzés ként adatott vagy
adatik vagy tesszük hát én csak
megköszönni tudom ivékszóként ezt a
tökéletes köszönöm szépen hogy itt
voltál és hogy tényleg én úgy érzem a
mélyire tudtunk menni a legmélyebb amit
eddig meg tudtam fogalmazni ezeknek a
kérdéseknek a mélyre tudtunk hatolni és
igazából még tudnék beszélgetni mert
mert valójában a jegyzeteim alapján még
a felét beszéltük át azoknak a témáknak
amikről amikről beszélgethettünk volna
de kezdtem is elfáradni az az igazság ez
egy intenzív beszélgetés volt és a
kedves hallgatókat is kérem arra hogy
jelezzetek vissza a kommentbe azért hogy
kapjunk mi is visszajelzést hogy
tetszett-e ez a lehet hogy fél év múva
megismételjük lehet hogy onnan
folytatjuk ahol most abbahagytuk hogyha
tényleg értékes volt ez a beszélgetés
számotokra is számomra egy értékes
beszélgetés volt úgy visszaidéztem
azokat az emlékeket amiket egy évvel
ezelőtt összeszedtem és úgy éreztem
akkor hogy valójában ez véd meg amikor
már a mesterévé válok egy információnak
akkor az megvéd megvéd engem és fd már
is mesélt egy ilyen példát hogy volt egy
abuzív apa amelyik szexuálisan
bántalmazta a a lányát és a lány úgy
tudott meg menekülni ettől a szorongóér
éstől amit felnőttként is folyamatosan
kísérte hogy hogy elment és fekete öves
lett egy egy karatéba például és valahol
az hogyha rájövünk hogy nem vagyunk
áldozatok hogy hogy meg
tudjuk olyan kontrollált monstrumokká
tudjuk magunkat nevelni akik képesek
arra hogy magukat visszafogják hogy jóra
használják azt az erő ami azt az erőt
ami bennük van de ha akarnának tudnának
ártani is na ez az ami megvéd minket
amikor rájövünk arra hogy hogy sokkal
több az ember mint aminek gondoljuk
magunkat mert ameddig kicsi áldozatnak
gondoljuk magunkat addig keserű kétségbe
esettek vagyunk de amikor amikor amikor
már látjuk azt hogy ha akarnánk tudnánk
ártani de mégsem tesszük na abban a
pillanatban jön el a szabadság pontosan
a belső szabadság a belső szabadság igen
pontosan köszönöm szépen hogy itt voltál
én is köszönöm szépen meg viszont sé ha
tetszett ez a műsor akkor iratkozz fel
kérlek a csatornánkra ezzel tudsz
támogatni minket köszönjük a vekker
kávéközösségnek a jó kávé ért az
ötvösudvarnak a helyért valamint a
bizalomtőkének a támogatásért nékületek
nem jöhetett volna ez létre